Tucker Carlson is back he put up a video
on Twitter saying that he'll be
launching a new show on Twitter and the
News comes after it was reported that
Tucker Carlson met with Elon Musk now
the interpretation for most people was
that they came to some kind of Accord
but Elon Musk came out and said there's
no deal Tucker is just gonna do a show
on Twitter but we will see it feels like
what they're really saying is they have
not signed anything and this could be
for legal reasons due to Tucker's
current contract with Fox News but it
does seem like Tucker and Elon have a
plan of sorts so this is big interesting
stuff but there's more news in the
Tucker front
apparently it's being reported he was
fired as part of the Dominion settlement
as if to imply that Dominion was like
okay we'll set up you gotta fire trucker
Carlson which is very very strange to
say the least so we'll talk about that
plus a whole bunch of other stories my
friends before we get started head over
to castbrew.com to pick up your cast
brew coffee I don't have the bag with me
today because we're actually drinking it
this morning but you can pick up one of
four special Blends rise with Roberto Jr
Appalachian Knights and then we have a
Colombian and a French roast supporting
the show uh if you if you buy from
Casper you're supporting the show
because we're sponsoring ourselves we're
trying to get away from being beholden
to corporate sponsors as it pertains to
generating Revenue so head over to
casper.com if you want to pick up some
good coffee uh my favorite is rise with
Roberto Jr to be completely this is a
light roast but if you like dark roast I
got Appalachian nights and uh it's gonna
be part of our coffee shop that we're
gonna be opening up hopefully across the
country very soon but either way the
first one is already underway we are
already building it out plus our social
club so again casper.com don't forget to
head over to timcast.com click join us
become a member and you'll get access to
exclusive members only uncensored shows
on the front page of timcast.com Monday
through Thursday at about 10 10 p.m
Eastern
we'll have one of those shows for you
tonight and as a member you can join our
Discord server hang out with like-minded
individuals and actually submit
questions to our show and even call into
our show for the members only uncensored
so smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Michael Heiss
thanks for having me Tim who are you sir
well as you said Michael Heiss I'm the
founder and chair of the libertarian
party mises caucus we're a group of
rabble rousers Libertarians and then
kind of the the Ron Paul Dave Smith Tom
Woods tradition and uh you know after a
long fight we took over the libertarian
party last year to uh to make it more
based proud to say that we might be the
only institution in the entire country
that de-wokified that where the
libertarian party kind of went woke and
a lot of people were disappointed with
that well we came in here to reverse
course and uh we made that happen last
year and now we're launching all of our
kind of plans and our political
strategies and anybody who's looked at
the libertarian party can tell that
something serious has changed with the
messaging looking forward forward to
that a presidential announcement coming
soon but I think we all are we'll see
what happens we also have Ben Stewart
hanging out that's right uh Ben Stewart
documentary filmmaker you can go to Ben
josephstewart.com I usually talk about
things like Consciousness and
psychedelics but I think I skipped
timelines and now I'm talking about the
Federal Reserve yeah we've got that uh
it's our second documentary well we have
two documentaries we have infringed and
then we have yours on the Federal
Reserve both of which will be coming out
soon so excited for that thanks for
hanging out Ben yeah man Sheamus is here
my name is Sheamus I have a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes where we
release an animated cartoon twice a week
we just released one today that I think
you guys will really really uh enjoy the
fans seem to be loving it if y'all want
to go check that out and I also have a
podcast on Rumble which is called shamer
we released that episode of that today
as well right on
hello everybody I'm uh philibonti uh
lead singer of All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
and
I am search.com I'm ready to go when you
guys are let's get it here's the first
big news from timcast.com we're back
Tucker Carlson to stream new show
through Twitter saying the news you
consume is a lie you are being
manipulated you know what how about we
just play the actual clip from Tucker
himself here we go hey it's Tucker
Carlson you often hear people say the
news is full of lies but most of the
time that's not exactly right much of
what you see on television or read the
New York Times is in fact true in the
literal sense it could pass one of the
media's own fact checks lawyers would be
willing to sign off on it in fact they
may have but that doesn't make it true
it's not true at the most basic level
the news you consume is a lie a lie of
the stealthiest and most Insidious kind
facts have been withheld on purpose
along with proportion and perspective
you are being manipulated how does that
work let's see if I tell you that a man
has been unjustly arrested for armed
robbery that is not strictly speaking a
lie he may have been framed at this
point there's been no trial so no one
can really say
but if I don't mention the fact that the
same man has been arrested for the same
crime six times before am I really
informing you no I'm not I'm misleading
you and that's what the news media are
doing in every story that matters every
day of the week every week of the year
what's it like to work in a system like
that after more than 30 years in the
middle of it we could tell you Stories
the best you can hope for in the news
business at this point is the freedom to
tell the fullest truth that you can but
there are always limits and you know
that if you bump up against those limits
often enough you will be fired for it
that's not a guess it's guaranteed every
person who works in English language
media understands that the rule of what
you can't say defines everything it's
filthy really and it's utterly
corrupting you can't have a free Society
if people aren't allowed to say what
they think is true speech is the
fundamental prerequisite for democracy
that's why it's enshrined in the first
of our constitutional amendments
amazingly as of tonight there aren't
many platforms left that allow Free
Speech the last big one remaining in the
world the only one is Twitter where we
are now
Twitter has long served as the place
where our national conversation
incubates and develops Twitter is not a
partisan site everybody's allowed here
and we think that's a good thing
and yet for the most part the news that
you see analyzed on Twitter comes from
media organizations that are themselves
thinly disguised propaganda Outlets you
see it on cable news you talk about it
on Twitter
the result may feel like a debate but
actually The Gatekeepers are still in
charge
we think that's a bad system we know
exactly how it works and we're sick of
it
starting soon we'll be bringing a new
version of the show we've been doing for
the last six and a half years to Twitter
we bring some other things too which
we'll tell you about but for now we're
just grateful to be here free speech is
the main right that you have without it
you have no others see you soon
so Elon Musk responded to all the news
saying on this platform unlike the
one-way Street of broadcast people are
able to interact critique and refute
whatever is said and of course anything
misleading will get community notes I
also want to be clear that we have not
signed a deal of any kind whatsoever
Tucker is subject to the same rules and
rewards of all content creators rewards
means subscriptions and advertising
Revenue share coming soon which is a
function of how many people subscribe in
the advertising views associated with
content not that many others
particularly from the left also choose
to be the content creators on this
platform now I I see what elon's got
going on here we have not signed a deal
of any kind whatsoever that does not
mean they did not shake hands and come
to an agreement because we had this
story from Forbes Elon Musk talking with
Tucker Carlson about working together
I don't believe that Tucker Carlson
would walk away from launching his own
network and making 100 million plus per
year on subscriptions unless there was
some kind of deal in place be it verbal
not a contractual agreement
I imagine that there is probably some
kind of deal in that as they said
there's going to be the subscriptions
and stuff like that and I imagine that
Elon essentially went to Tucker and said
look the money's there blah blah blah
we'll we'll make sure that you get the
reach you have this many Etc this is how
it'll work with the way that we're
thinking and so I can assure you that
you know give you my word that this will
will be and it may be just a handshake
deal like you said
um but it doesn't see I don't see you
know I don't think that that he'll have
a problem coming up with money he's the
the I just think that there's no reason
for anyone to do a show on Twitter
unless Elon makes a guarantee you like
YouTube subsidizes content yeah I think
but the thing is I think that there's a
lot of people I think there's more
people that are like you that the money
isn't you know the issue like Tucker
doesn't understand talking about this uh
with Michael downstairs the the money
like Tucker's already rich he's already
gonna make you know never gonna have to
worry about money in his life so I just
feel like he's looking for
um for reach and for probably security
and I think that the money is a
secondary thing I mean it's not like I
hear about it you know I agree but I
mean money money is secondary you want
to do something good you want to say
what you have to say and you want people
to see it but money is like the the the
oil for the machine fair so I don't
think Tucker is going to want to look at
his net worth his bank account his
assets and back let's liquidate this
property so that I can do a show he's
probably gonna be like how can I fund a
show how can I make money that being
said it may be that Elon simply went to
Tucker and said you do your show on
Twitter we absorb all of the costs of
broadcast
hosting server and everything and so
Tucker might be thinking about it like
okay we'll do subscriptions we'll make
money on Twitter that way Elon says they
only take 10 so what am I really losing
and they're gonna they're gonna cover
all the hosting costs done I just
imagine that that there's there's plenty
of money to be made and plenty of
avenues for him to make money and that
the the essentially the teaming up of
you know the two kind of biggest Free
Speech names going really puts up puts
pressure on all of the other media like
this is the mo this is going to be the
most pressure that all of the other
media Outlets have probably ever
experienced it could be Paradigm
shifting I mean one we don't know what
the restrictions that Tucker has on him
that would maybe prevent him from
discussing the money and revenues from
this sort of content but you know look
at what happened with musk himself he
put a portion of his fortune up to try
to do something good with Twitter
because he saw you know what was going
on with the collusion and and the lack
of free speech on Twitter so if we're
lucky we're going to get something
similar with Tucker himself where you
know maybe what what Elon uh is doing
with Twitter they are now trying to do
to YouTube and and kind of create a new
paradigm in the content creator Hub yeah
I mean I feel like that's what I feel
like this is more about the the
conversation that you know the discourse
that's going on the national discourse
than it is about him being concerned
about monetary you know you know how
much money he's going to make because
again it's already rich and these guys
are the dudes that are out there
carrying the torch for actual liberalism
in an age when you've got so many
progressives that are really
authoritarian and really really strongly
looking to you know censor speech and
say this is outside of the the realm of
of acceptable conversation the the
opportunity right now is for anybody who
wants to launch a show needs to launch
it on Twitter right now 100 because
what's going to happen is within the
next year Elon is going to be looking at
propping up whatever shows and content
they have and what elon's not going to
want to do is start trying to poach
outside content because it's very
difficult I would love to have Tim cast
IRL live every day on Twitter I've got
1.6 million followers it would be
fantastic I think we get tremendous
reach it's just difficult to do and I
don't know what the upside is other than
just General reach it's an investment I
understand but it's kind of out of side
out of mind if we invested in
multi-streaming did the show on Twitter
did a live stream or whatever because
they have that capability I don't know
what we would get out of it so Elon
let's say he comes to us and he's like
we want you on on Twitter I'd be like
okay here's what we need to cover the
costs of that hiring somebody to do it
et cetera et cetera if somebody just
launches a show on Twitter right now
when Elon is looking for content to put
in the suggested feed it will be you so
that's that's that's how it always works
when YouTube first started there were
people who made no money and just did it
and then when YouTube started expanding
they promoted those people those people
became rich and famous so
I don't know man Tucker doesn't need it
I'm wondering what the conversation was
let me uh let me pull up what Forbes had
to say Forbes said that Elon Musk has
been talking with former Fox News host
Tucker Carlson about possibly working
together according to a new report from
axios the news comes after Carlson was
abruptly pulled off the air by Fox blah
blah blah they said that axios had
learned that Carlson and Elon Musk had a
conversation about working together but
didn't discuss specifics
I don't know I don't know where we go
who Tucker is as well it's a big
signpost who Tucker is and him coming
here it's it's definitely him his face
and a new turning point for Twitter so
that's that's pretty cool convergence
right there but is this going to drive
the left off of Twitter into places like
blue sky or Mastodon or something
because they're already attacking
Twitter for oh you're gonna host Tucker
you're already taking Twitter saying
you're gonna host uh Tucker Carlson it
is interesting he even he even says that
I hope that many others particularly on
the left will make some comments let's
just look man
elon's light to the party I'm glad he's
at the party but he's late to the party
he posts that Meme of you know the
person the the the left moving further
and further left and then makes that
makes a moderate right wing and it's
like bro that was 10 years ago that
happened 10 years ago and you got to the
party like two years ago yeah we're all
so early though Tim like weird like
people that are plugged in are extremely
early and and normies are just catching
wind to this and I think that you know
the whole covid thing is I mean I don't
wanna I'm a little hesitant to say this
but one of them actually I'll say it
like this one of the uh benefits one of
the the Silver Linings of kovid was it
woke people up to the the control that
the of the narrative from the left and
from the government and it made people
realize the government was really
interested in censoring and really
interested in controlling what is and
isn't allowed to be said so I I
understand your frustration I just feel
like
this is a little frustrated well I mean
I understand your point but I I just
think that this is really we're so ahead
of the curve like and I'm just saying
it's wishful thinking Elon I don't I
think doesn't understand he understands
a little bit but he's new to this the
left is a cult yes we had Lance from the
surfs on this show who admitted I I
asked him okay earmuffs for your kids
I'll keep it family friendly to the best
of my abilities I said if you went into
MGM National Harbor you know it's it's
just south of DC it's this big shopping
center casino and loudly proclaimed what
you previously said previously said and
what he what did he say let's just put
it this way he claimed that if a if a
straight male or I'm sorry that if a
male engaged in adult activities with a
biological male who was trans it wasn't
in fact gay he said it in a different
way but much more graphic much more
graphic description and I said if you
ask the average person when they agreed
he said no of course not I'm like you're
in a cult if you believe so strongly in
this world view and you know no one
agrees with you at all like the majority
of the world you are the odd person out
you are on the wrong side of history and
so with that being said I think Elon
doesn't understand the extent to which
the left is in a cult and unwilling to
engage and willing to burn things down
for their cult well I mean there's
definitely truth in that I'll also add
this though I think there is some fear
that people are you know expressing here
about the potential for left-wing people
to leave the platform I think a lot of
people who are True Believers are pretty
far to the left would leave your average
normal run-of-the-mill left-wing person
probably would not and part of the
reason these platforms were able to get
away with censoring conservatives for so
long is because they weren't all that
afraid of like sort of a small
contingent of conservatives really far
to the right leaving and so I think
based on the same Market principles
there's not that much of a risk of
people on the left leaving well I don't
I don't care if they leave I'm not
saying that they should stay I think
this is a good thing because I think
here's what's going to happen my point
is I think taking Twitter was one of the
most powerful things you could do in the
culture War Elon Musk nailed that yeah
because it's like you're saying the left
dominates the space and so default
liberals fall in line yeah but now with
the left fleeing it's actually a good
thing because that means the popular
accounts the big accounts the accounts
that people want to Aspire to be like
are going to be more moderate to
right-leaning and that means regular
people who are on the platform are going
to see more of that exactly okay I just
want to mention one more thing Twitter
does lean to the left but it's not you
know like Tumblr was where it's just
overwhelmingly left leaning in anyone
who goes there can sniff that out
immediate immediately and disregard most
of what they're seeing it's deceptive
because it almost seems more moderate
even though traditionally the user base
has been more left-wing but that's been
part of why it's been so powerful as a
tool for framing the narrative on the
part of the left people get the feeling
it's unbiased when it is really uh
Center left but I was going to say I I
think there is something to be said
about maintaining the Olive Branch to
people who are reasonable and sending
the incentives against the unreasonable
people we want them to leave so that we
can have legitimate conversation but
then you know you've got people out
there like RFK Junior he's on the left
and I think you know he's got some good
ideas and he seems like somebody who
doesn't hate us you know I don't agree
with him on gun control and stuff like
that but he seems like somebody who
doesn't hate us you know you've had
Destiny on this show he's at least
willing to engage I don't agree with him
on everything but he's at least willing
to engage and have the conversation uh
you've got the Jimmy doors of the world
and and you've got the walk away
movement where there is some level of
disgust with the cult mentality uh and
all of that so but then I think there's
something to be said about the album The
People you're naming are people who
agree on facts Jimmy Dore he's a social
I think he's a software proclaimed
socialist but he's like here's what the
news said and here's what we fact check
and here's what we found out to be true
he can bring that to us and we say yes
you are correct we we've analyzed the
facts and we agree on the facts then our
opinions differ and we're like well
that's okay all of our opinions differ
right you get someone like Destiny who
comes out and says Kyle Rittenhouse is
acting in self-defense and the left
comes after him he may be a liberal but
he's like hey this I watch it I'm not
gonna lie this is what happened and then
the cult are the people who are just
outright lying they will say whatever
whatever whatever needs to be said even
if it doesn't make sense for instance
you might have some left to say
something like a woman should be allowed
to abort her child at any point because
part of her body but she shouldn't be
allowed to do math because that would
intentionally kill the baby which is
just confusing because it's
contradictory in in in in in itself so
that to me is a cult member
yeah I think without the Olive Branch to
reasonable people you run the risk of
doing the same thing that's done that's
done to to the right where like you know
that Meme where
um like the guy is pushed from the left
and there and yeah um you know yeah and
they're like oh yeah are you okay why
are you associating with the right I
think if we don't have that and it's got
to be more less about ideas or or even
political philosophy more about
character
you know and people who are just
reasonable there's a lot I think there's
a lot of substance to that because one
of the things that I've experienced is
just in my life it has happened to be
that when I interact with with people on
the left I have felt like they're
exclusionary and this is again this is
this is anecdotal I know I understand I
understand that but like if you don't if
you're not welcoming you're not gonna
get anybody on your side like when All
That Remains got our start
the blogs that were giving me the most
crap were the ones that were on the left
so like I'm not going to feel any kind
of sympathetic you know any kind of
sympathy towards people that are on the
left when all the people that are
attacking me are from the left you know
you have to leave the door open and
there's going to be a left wing yes like
no matter what like unless you can
somehow like obliterate the the
connection between personality type and
political Association there is going to
be a left wing and I think I want to
promote a left wing that yeah is Jimmy
Dore left wing if you ask the
quote-unquote left they'll say no he's
far right that's insane yes and that's
where we're at so they're they're right
now in this country there are actual
left and actual right who are friends
and having good conversations and trying
to move things forward and that would be
like the Jimmy door and the Tucker
Carlson having that conversation but
what we refer to now as left and right
isn't even political it's cult and not
cult yeah and Jimmy Dore is probably the
best example of that and then to a
lesser degree someone like me right like
moderate centers but they call right
wing well the left will make arguments
like yeah but look at this he voted for
Trump I'm like yeah I did vote for Trump
Jimmy Dore does not like Donald Trump
but they still call right wing that is
that is insane you voted for Trump and
like 15 years ago Trump was a Democrat
right people on the right would have
said he's but that's left that's their
argument the argument from the left is
when people say I'm a regular I'm just a
regular person from 10 years ago they
say that's what conservative means they
were like uh the argument the left makes
is in night if someone from 1950 in 1970
said you know I'm not uh conservative
I'm just a regular person from 15 years
ago they would say yeah before civil
rights like yes so you are right wing
you are conservative because you're not
with the times or whatever the
difference today is left and right in
the sense of uh our politics cultural
traditional versus uh economic you know
communal systems or Capital systems mean
absolutely nothing Jimmy Dora socialist
is right wing you can you can deviate
from leftist Economic Policy but you
can't deviate from social cult policy
even if it doesn't make sense like when
that dude said you know you can take
math or you can't a woman can't take
math because it'll kill the baby but you
can't kill the baby yeah like that just
it literally makes no sense as long as
he is saying words that align with the
quote unquote left the cult then you're
left that's it even even I think the
funny thing about the whole debate is
Sheamus over here as he often is as a
pro-life guy he's not even saying
anything and me the traditional
pro-choice guy argued with the
pro-abortion guy and he's calling me
pro-life right wing well forced birther
and I part of it was I I didn't it's so
stupid I didn't want to Dogpile him but
there were one or two moments I mean
there were a few moments where he said
things that were blatantly factually
incorrect but then when he was saying
incorrect related to health care for
children and trying to justify
mutilation I had to jump in I mean but I
mean I just to correct the nonsense he
was taking no but yeah part of why I was
remaining quiet wasn't because I was
like oh man like obviously you know I
believe this is an incredibly important
issue it's incredibly important to me
but I thought they're having the
discussion and it might be in bad taste
if this was a jumping I'm not trying to
rehash that episode no I'm just trying
to point out that I'm clearly at odds
with you on a lot of these issues as
someone who's like moderate slightly
left living on the issue but to their
perspective he's he's equating you and I
together despite the fact that we
disagree which is a huge compliment for
you you know what I mean
yes yes of course but uh let let's jump
to this next story because this one's
pretty shocking that's from the post
millennial Carlson was told by a member
of the fox board that he was taken off
the air as part of the Dominion
settlement per Tucker's legal team two
people brief in the conversation told
axios that Carlson had been told by a
fox board member that he was taken off
the air abruptly last month as part of a
settlement with Dominion voting systems
the 787 million settlement million
dollar settlement for each of the two
parties came less than a week after it
was revealed Carlson was off the air in
a letter from Carlson's lawyers to Fox
News they argue that Carlson's
non-compete clause in his contract which
runs through 2025 is no longer valid
alleging Fox employees including Robert
Murdoch himself broke promises to
Carlson intentionally and with Reckless
disregard for the truth the lawyers
accused Fox Executives with two uh which
two sources told the axios are Viet den
and Murdoch of making material
misrepresentations were promises to
Carlson that was intentionally broken
constituting fraud the Revelation comes
as Tucker Carlson has launched a new
show on Twitter so this is kind of crazy
the reporting that Dominion basically
told Fox you've got a fire Tucker
Carlson and then why would they do it
let's break this down you gotta fire
Tucker Carlson and almost a billion
dollars but consider this
I I do a contract with somebody they
can't abruptly fire me without cause
contracts will have terms and if you do
your contract right it gives you some
protections so I've done contracts
before with networks and they've all
said if you terminate the show remove
him or in any way inhibit his work it
will constitute a a you know a a breach
of contract and you know party will be
responsible for paying out the full
amount of the contract you know there
and or whatever so if you do a contract
for a million bucks over three years
and then six months in they say your
show's off the air you gotta pay me the
million bucks right now that is the
contract agreement and so typically they
don't like to do that to break this
contract with Tucker Carlson
implies Dominion was going after more
money so so basically the cost benefit
analysis comes in and Fox News says how
much money will we lose if we defy
Dominion is it going to be another 100
200 300 million how much do we lose if
Tucker sues us fire Talker by the way I
could be mistaken here but if I'm
correct Tucker wasn't really blaming
Dominion he was the election outcomes
yes it was this is the crazy thing about
it Tucker is the guy who said to Sydney
Powell come on my show and I'll give you
all the time in the world to prove your
claims where's the evidence and he got
attacked by Trump supporters for it so
why would Dominion want him out I don't
know because maybe the people who work
at Dominion are just cult members and
they're like here's our opportunity to
strike at the heart of Fox News well and
then they would they would lump all
dissident conservatives in under the
category of election denial or whatever
whatever label they're using no let me
let me ask you guys this question
why won't the left go after Hannity
why why is Tucker Carlson the target
despite the fact that new Carlson
overlaps with the left on a ton of
issues because he's moving the Overton
window populism yep economic populism
anti-war yet they attack him exclusively
he's the closest to anti-government like
Sean Hannity is is not anti-government
at any you know by any stretch of the
imagination he'll talk about small
government but Sean Hannity is the
as typical of a republican that as as
you can probably get Tucker Carlson for
all his
for all the fact that he used to be a
Democrat like back in the day and and
I'm sure that he's comfortable with a
big with a with a fairly large
government too he's still
anti-establishment so even if he's he
would want a big government he doesn't
want the type of big government that we
have now so I imagine that's why he gets
the heat that he does didn't Tucker
Carlson recently call himself a liberal
I mean he did support Ron Paul when he
was running yeah oh yeah yeah and when
he I think when he says liberal he means
like liberal yeah right and I would say
I mean Hannity is part of the the
conservative ink cult yes you know like
and and so at some point you know the
Colts all do their own thing but don't
come after each other it's the people
who step outside of the cult outside of
the the you know the three by the
allowable uh opinion uh that that have
to be taken out and have to be you know
made out to be crazy shout out to Tom
Woods for that three by five absolutely
how did he support Ron Paul
I think he openly vocally did and I'm
pretty sure if I remember correctly when
Ron Paul spoke uh at his counter event
to the GOP National Convention that
Tucker Carlson spoke there don't quote
me on that but I think he did but he was
vocally insupportive Ron Paul well yeah
and I think they also want to go after
someone who they
perceive as weak because they're outside
of one of those bubbles right when
you're standing on your own there aren't
going to be as many people who have your
back when they start running hit pieces
on you it's it's much easier to take you
out
I wonder how effective that will be Now
with uh you know with you know the
largest communications platform I I
maybe I don't know that's the irony he's
he he's he hasn't
like evolved into his ultimate form and
now he has the room to do that yeah I
mean it's it's definitely going to be
you know it's definitely going to be uh
extremely interesting to see what does
happen
um I kind of smelled that he was going
to go to Twitter I was been talking
about it because
musk has made comments about when he
bought Twitter he was thinking you know
there's no place like WeChat in the U.S
so like we chatting in China you can pay
for everything you can watch videos and
Etc and he when he bought Twitter he was
thinking oh I think that you know we
should make Twitter I think I think it's
gonna work I think so too yeah yeah I'm
thinking about uh there he's already
responded saying like Twitter TV app or
something like that Twitter Live app so
that you can open your TV and watch
Twitter videos people are gonna be
producing video content he's already got
the subscriptions going that's the first
thing he has to do people subscribe to
content that generates revenue for the
person which gets them to use the
platform more it generates revenue for
Twitter it puts patreon out of business
it's a big threat to rumble as well
considering he's allowing Free Speech
but I'm really excited about patreon
imploding because uh there's no way you
can compete you've got your followers on
Twitter already patreon is where you try
to direct them if they're already on
Twitter you can just click that little
button right there yeah hey you follow
me click that button boom you got a new
subscriber so it's way easier to convert
your existing fan base Elon knew this I
think him going after Twitter to buy it
in the first place it had a lot more to
do with just the than just the Babylon B
uh people were talking about how this is
actually an effective app for
communicating over long distances like
sending messages from Mars for instance
yeah exactly you post it and you let it
go and then it appears and it appears so
I think elon's got big plans I'm just
I'm still waiting I can't stand he was
saying he was he was kind of late for
the party
um he even admitted uh after openai
launched gpt4 he's gonna get you know
start training his own llm he knows he's
late to the party there but you know
there's something where there's all
these pots in the fire that he's got
going that I think either he has an idea
of where they're all they may converge
in the future or he's just actually
trying out a bunch of things and seeing
what works I'm excited to see what
happens with Twitter but you know with
this llm thing what's llm the large
language models like you know GPT right
so yeah he's gonna start training his
own one he said he's going to call it
truth GPT right which you know will
basically just not have the the biases
stuff like that in there and he knows
he's behind the curve but you know if
anyone behind the curve can do it is
probably him I've been using a mid
Journey a lot you may have seen I I
posted a picture on Twitter which I
think is very important actually I'm
going to pull it up right now I think it
is one of the most important images of
this or any generation let me uh let me
just try and scroll down here and I
think it's uh I think it's gonna be
right here let me pull this one over
there you go ladies and gentlemen the
most important photo America's back baby
uh for those are just listening it's a
picture of Donald Trump and Sonic the
Hedgehog running in Washington DC for
some reason and then I have this picture
of Donald Trump shaking hands with Sonic
the Hedgehog for some reason but I've
been using uh mid journey and so it is
interesting to see where we go like this
photo of Donald Trump looks real I mean
son of the Hedgehog obviously does not
look real he's not it's not a real thing
but uh the photo of trump looks like
it's actually Trump running and we've
already seen a bunch of photos of him
getting arrested and things like that it
took me 10 seconds to do this I just
typed it in as a bit Donald Trump
running besides the Hedgehog enter boom
30 seconds goes by and it just pops up
on the screen so things are starting to
get crazy
I think it'll be I don't know I want to
bring it up I think it'll be fascinating
to see where these where this AI stuff
goes especially if Elon Musk is getting
involved and especially if the Twitter
Firehouse is plugged right into the
language and learning model it's going
to create it's it's going to create some
kind of weird Borg structure a hive mind
of all of our thoughts
no oh my gosh all of our thoughts from
Twitter yeah that thing's gonna be
horrible it's just gonna be Pepe it's
going to be just like a big frog and
it's like I am incarnate I am Keck and
we're gonna be like wow it happened the
creating of the world as a filmmaker
they have uh Speech to Text I follow the
code report and you know a bunch of
videos like that and it's just insane
with the amount of plugins I was just
watching something today that was saying
actually it was uh it wasn't the open
letter where people were saying we need
to slow down AI it was another one
saying that the the ones who aren't
doing it open sourced actually are
having a big uh a hindrance because all
the open source ones seem to be evolving
a lot faster did you uh what have you
heard of that video AI That's like mid
Journey you can type in walking through
a forest during at night and it will
generate a video of walking through the
force and now you've seen that one yeah
it can do just speech to text or just
speech to um to video and it's only a
couple seconds long but just remember
anyone listening that's that's the worst
it's gonna look and it doesn't look that
bad right now I've seen the videos and
it's nuts there's apps right now where
you'll have people on their phones just
filming themselves like you know running
through their house or something like
that and then within with a few prompts
and 10 seconds later the whole landscape
around turns into like you know he's
he's now wearing Indiana Jones type
stuff and the place he's in is like an
under underground catacombs or something
this is actually why another good reason
I think Twitter might end up being the
place in terms of the internet
because if it's it's a platform where
people are just sharing ideas and Elon
does get this stuff integrated we're
coming to the point where look man I'm
an artist
I made that picture of Elon I'm sorry of
Donald Trump and some Hedgehog running
in Washington DC you had a brand as you
did it well you know if look if someone
uses a paintbrush to make an image
they're using a tool to do it we don't
it's still their image now at the point
where the the the the canvas and the
paintbrush is literally just an AI you
tell it what to make you refine it it is
your art and it feels a lot of people
probably disagree but we're not going to
be thinking that in 10 20 years people
are going to be like that was so
creative creative of you to make that
movie they're gonna be like Sheamus that
that feature-length film you made last
night was incredible I I enjoyed the
whole thing thanks I enjoyed it too no
problem I appreciate it but you're
you're going to say you're all by myself
actually right right now check it out
they have apps where you can animate
images
you can post a picture of a person and
then type send in text or I play an
audio file and it will sync the the
photo with the audio file we've already
seen the stuff where people are singing
right we did the music video genocide
where we had like Taylor Lorenz singing
our song you can they have high
resolution versions of it someone mid
used mid journey to generate a Sci-Fi
looking spaceship Captain female then
they wrote out with uh text-to-speech
program a paragraph they then took that
audio file and put it in this program
with the image and made her talk that
was like one plus two equals three
imagine someone in a year having a
program that is all of that instantly
and then once you have those things all
you got to do is is Type in a movie
about a space Captain leaving Earth to
go find a new Colony but gets betrayed
by the first mate and then aliens come
and the first mate was working with
aliens the whole time and then it will
just render the whole movie like that
it's crazy and it's all based upon the
language models because there's a ton of
different AI models but then all of a
sudden in 2017 rolls around and the
language models start doing what the
other models weren't able to do like
language models can now do chemistry
better than chemistry AI which is
trained specifically for that
um it's starting to progress where
everyone who is in all these other camps
of AI they're only focusing on one
platform which means the progress is
going to go that much faster let's let's
jump to this next story ladies and
gentlemen we have this tweet from BBC
News World wait what is this it says why
some people some people what do you mean
by some people oh my God are spreading
false rumors about the Texas government
Sheamus what do they mean some people uh
I don't know exactly what they mean now
I'm I'm gonna assume this is some kind
of racist dog whistle because that's
what it sounds like it is and then they
post this this picture of me right and
you know it looks like they've darkened
my skin I just can't believe some people
yeah what does this mean
um I do think it's hilarious that they
said some people have just sang my name
and also how do people are spreading
false rumors also like a picture of me
well no and this is this is what's
really Insidious about this right so
they have some people that refers to a
group and then Texas gunman which refers
to one person so your brain goes to the
picture of the person there is the
gunman so it looks it really does when I
first saw this I was like oh is this
like a meme or something that like look
at the lefties are trying to joke that
Tim is responsible for this and so
they're possible so no they literally
posted your image actually Sinclair said
the same notice the same thing she
tweeted about she said that she said
that it was like disgusting that yeah I
made that title because it does look
like they're saying or implying that Tim
is the shooters yeah no it seriously it
does look like that it looks like that
it really does pick the picture that you
know could somewhat closely look like a
mug shot yeah oh
wowed it up a little bit if Tim made a
mob Deep album cover it would be that it
would be that picture yeah that's a fair
point because saying some people as a
reference to multiple people but that's
exactly singular Texas gunman and
showing the image is to imply that was
me I think I might have to BBC I'm going
to sue you you got it you got to change
that I'm I'm gonna sue you I'm telling
you check it out though here's what they
say why some people are spreading false
rumors about the Texas gunman I this
article is actually hilarious because it
gives you a bunch of patter fluff
nonsense in the beginning that means
nothing that there's no point in Reading
it's just like there's a guy and he'll
be shooting people blah blah blah what
did the suspect post blah blah blah how
do we in no how do we know the account
was his my favorite part the BBC has
examined the material and we can be
confident the suspect was the person
behind the posts hey confidence is not
confirmation so this is an opinion piece
BBC well so hold on yeah why are they
confident be like where's that outside
is coming from I know what their
confidence is coming from it fits their
narrative look at this look at this it
says Garcia appeared use the account uh
as an online diary he posted multiple
documents including his name date of
birth and other identifying details
including a plane ticket a speeding
ticket and an ID card
this is what we call in the business an
orgy of evidence
well I think you guys you guys get that
reference when you walk into a crime
scene and you see like all the documents
laid out perfectly it's like oh boy I
believe that wasn't that from Seven
where they talked about it no that was a
Minority Report there you go they go
into the room and there's all the photos
of Tom Cruise's kid and then uh Colin
Farrell's like this is what we call an
orgy of evidence it's it's not but it's
not believable like you walk in and
they're just like look here's the guy
who did it I think it's it's almost like
as absurd as if could you imagine if
there's a story that's as crazy as to
suggest that like maybe a plane crashed
and then like a passport survived the
Fireball and landed on the ground
thousands of people oh my gosh in the
rubble if you could believe that yeah
and then uh anyway it says uh despite
the clear evidence the clear evidence
yeah that's a that's an opinion right
there yeah several activists and
internet personalities including at
least one mentioned in Garcia's post
have attempted to cast doubt on the
authenticity of the material they've
claimed without evidence that it's part
of a psychological operation or false
flag by the government to smear those on
the right or far right well I didn't I
didn't say any of that later stuff false
flag I did say psyop but psyop in in
could include corporations in private
sector as well so you see how they they
they expand upon it take what you say
and then add context to it but I love
how they're then they're just like at
the bottom like a picture of me adding
to the misinformation blah blah blah
they say uh what is it the podcaster Tim
Poole a former Occupy Wall Street
supporter and Vice news reporter was
among those mentioned several times I
got a I got a message earlier today
because the USA Today also talked about
me and they called me a former
journalist I'm like oh okay sure thanks
they're so they're so threatened there's
no evidence that Garcia was inspired to
action by Mr pool's podcasts which cover
right-wing talking points and
conspiracies oh my gosh Mr pool
immediately tried to cast doubt on the
veracity to the material accusing those
digging up the material as being part of
a psyop yes yes uh BBC your opinion
piece is interesting to me but please
spare me your opinion piece and don't
use my photo in the way you did but I
would like to point out
um what do we have here a couple weeks
before this this incident someone
started posting random photos from
Reddit and posting uh four clips from
Tim cast IRL a single episode and making
a photo post about Libs of tick tock to
no followers to nobody for what reason a
a Mexican Neo-Nazi inspired by a a
Jewish woman and a mixed race Korean guy
is is what what are they trying to imply
here and the Nazi stuff I just think is
the most absurd considering they're like
Libs of tick tock is great it's like
higher right check is Jewish
stupidest thing I've ever heard of and
so anyway
that's the story and then I go that
sounds like BS oh wait but BBC better
write up a whole article about it and
put his picture in it well thanks for
that BBC appreciate it
the existence of the CIA at all means
that all conspiracy theories are at
least plausible
period if it exists like how many times
has there been you know covert
operations that have come to light that
the CIA was involved in coin uh cointel
Pro what was it called
so this is this is Belling cat that uh
uncovered this uh this this profile how
like the serious question a balancat
researcher just so happened to be
browsing Russian social media
underground Russian social media and
found a profile with no followers come
on dude the same guy that connected the
um New York Times with the uh
the Ukraine it's information laundering
what they do is they bellingcat can
write whatever they want and then say oh
look at this this is interesting then
the media writes it up and they can't be
sued that's how it works and
bellingcat's a non-profit which is very
very difficult to get money out of so in
my humble opinion I believe at the very
least the balling cat people are so bad
at their jobs they genuinely believe
random garbage on the internet let me
tell you how easy it is make a profile
make 10 profiles post a series of images
about a specific individual you want to
smear so uh right now someone could go
on a Russian website and make a profile
where they post a bunch of pictures of
Hasidic Jewish Nazis seemingly making no
sense no pictures of faces or anything
like that they can then write posts and
then wait and then as soon as something
happens they can take the picture of the
individual upload it as the profile
picture then add demographic information
birth date location and the BBC will be
like well the birth date matches that
proves it even though they made the
profile in advance and I'm not saying
it's a having to do it and I'm not
saying that it's an intelligence
intelligence agency I'm saying literally
any activist can do this right now any
random person sitting in their mom's
basement can do this right now so for
you to be like we're confident it's it's
actually the account is just nonsense
well again these are shut up the people
who believe Jessie small at right right
the people who believe Jessie a small
lot yeah well you don't is it I know all
the bad guys and I'm just saying look
like it it's just I think if you did
have a lunatic who had posted a couple
clips from Tim's show obviously it goes
without saying that that doesn't make
Tim at all culpable for the behavior of
That League so yeah the clips Joe he
wasn't even subscribed to the channel
wow right like he's a fan like he wasn't
even subscribed it was it was four clips
from one show but yeah so my point is
this is grasping at straws right because
even if they can definitively prove even
if it turns out that this is legitimate
that really is this guy's profile
they're telling the truth and they have
good reasons to be confident that still
is not the nail in the coffin that they
think it is here I I mean I gotta be
honest like I think it's funny and I
really just don't care I think we've won
so much ground in the culture war that
it is completely meaningless that they
would even do it assuming it was a Psy
up it's just it means nothing to me it's
just it's just funny the fact that every
chance they get there they're just
slandering you know like musk or Tim
cast or whoever it is that is the uh
opposing view it's straight slander just
associations with the most terrible
organization in history the Nazis right
here that's just it's it shows that they
have no no substance here's our here's
how I responded Ian miles Chong tweeted
something out Keith olberman responded
saying sure it's suspect because your
side and Libs of tick tock got caught
inspiring a mass murderer blood on your
hands Fu and I said I really don't care
what the cult thinks like at all fart
fart Keith elberman I'd say you're dumb
as a box of rocks but that's a demeaning
to rocks
like I I just do I care about what
ranting raving lunatic Keith Olbermann
thinks he thought he thought Donald
Trump was a was a Russian spy like these
people are not smart people and there's
nothing like you know uh they try to
shame you and I'm just like I you know I
you can't shame me well your booze mean
nothing I've seen what makes you cheer
exactly I mean for for any story
especially if it's something that suits
their narrative you really need to see
hard proof from them in order to give it
any level of credibility but I just
don't care Keith olberman could come out
and be like look at this picture of a
thing happening and I just laugh at him
and like you are a really dumb guy and
your words are meaningless and there's
no reason for me to read them like there
is nothing Keith olberman can say that
will impact my life in any meaningful
way politically media wise I just I I
don't care about these people
but it's not just him it's like I've
gotten to the point where in the culture
War a leftist can come and start going
in my ears and I'm just like it does
nothing but it has no bearing whatsoever
it's like you said it's all it's all
about narrative control because I'm
ostensibly it's it's about oh there was
a shooting and it's tragic and you know
they want us to believe that this is a a
Mexican like it's a bold claim to say
it's a Mexican white supremacist and
they will they will use the tragedy to
obsessively run that narrative when at
the same time there was other shootings
that happened like there was a shooting
that happened in Tulsa Oklahoma right
around that same time
um you know I don't as far as I know
nobody watched your show on that
shooting so that's not the one that they
choose they choose the one where they
have to make the claim that it's a
Mexican white supremacist just to be
able to say that it's somebody who's
watching SO waiting on that uh Las Vegas
shooter motivation yeah remember that
one or the manifesto from the the
Covenant shooting so that that that that
Nashville incident as well as the Vegas
one we still haven't figured out those
have we that was 20 minutes from my my
daughter was going to a private school
like 20 minutes away from there they hit
close to home but yeah we don't we don't
hear much about that and that was a
Christian School the fact that the fact
that you have almost no info or had so
had to wait so long to get information
about the Nashville shooter the the
manifesto's still not out but this had
so much information the very next day
and you're not supposed to be suspect
you're if you're skeptical at all it's
it's it's verboten to be skeptical give
me a break and the other thing I've
noticed looking at the coverage of this
uh and this has to be part of the
narrative control too is every single
article has the same talking point of
over 200 mass shootings this year yeah
all of them and they all site the same
non-profit yeah and they all cite the
same non-profit uh that is saying this
now that non-profit says there's been
1200 defensive uses of guns that's
ridiculous anybody who knows about that
statistic knows that there's there's
hundreds of thousands of defensive uses
of guns every year so it makes you
wonder how the hell are they defining a
mass shooting to come to that number
it's usually three or more people being
injured by a firearm and so what they'll
do is this little bait and switch where
they have one definition of a mass
shooting that says something depending
on the definition you're looking at
either three people being injured with a
firearm or three people being killed and
when people hear mass shooting of course
they don't think that that's where the
bar is they're thinking of a school
shooting they're thinking of a large
group of people being massacred so yeah
I think three people being injured by a
firearm is a very different thing from a
public Massacre but you use the way the
term is used paints a picture that 200
separate times this year already there
have been these massive you know
Columbine level events exactly when you
use the phrase mass shooting it brings
to mind Columbine or Virginia Tech or
Parkland or any other horrible horrible
horrible shootings and when they say
when you're talking about 200 of them so
far this year they're talking about two
probably really terrible shootings and
990 and you know and 198 that are are
three people took rounds when two when a
drug deal went bad and that's what a bad
shooting is exactly and that's one thing
so a lot of it is like gang activities
drug deals someone pulling out a gun
again that's not a good thing that's not
a thing we want to tolerate in our
country we want to clean that up but
that is not something that belongs in
the same category as an event like a
school shoot yeah and that's the thing
it's this they're bringing to mind the
school shooting so it's the most
horrible event that you that that
happens in America it puts you in the
most emotional state where you might be
the most reactive and the most accepting
of a narrative it's also very
understanding of how people read
information like this one like you know
most people will read the headline
they'll read maybe the first couple
lines in there and they'll come to their
conclusions but you have to post
something like this BBC article
specifically because of the way that
people look for information we want to
confirm what we already kind of believe
so if we want to look up something like
this and we see it okay okay yeah sure
it makes perfect sense sense and you
know it writes off Tim in a very like
interesting dismissive way
so this is also very intelligent on how
people peruse their information and come
to their conclusions and just validate
what they've already been I particularly
like this headline from unheard don't
blame Tim Poole for the Texas mall
shooting that's really nice event
look at the picture too
I think I look pretty good but it's kind
of like a shrugging right I think that's
your outro actually what Eclipse your
outro one other thing that I want to
point out is that the Centrist media
personality see thank you unheard the
mass shooter stuff is actually dual use
right so one thing it it can demonize
people or groups of people they can use
to say oh these people are saying the
wrong things blah blah and on the second
point it gives them a route to attack
rifles which rifles are the tools that
will keep a tyrannical government at bay
that's why they are after rifles and
they're not after machine gun Sons
they're not after tank Busters grenades
thereafter rifles that's because of
Vietnam because of Afghanistan because
all over the world if you have a
population that's armed with rifles that
can take shots at three four five
hundred yards they can harass a
well-equipped army and they can
basically wait them out and that's the
last thing that the government wants to
have to deal with they want to get rid
of the rifles so that way they can go
ahead and say all right well we're going
to Institute this particular law that
violates your rights and people are in a
position or not in a position to say no
we're going to put our foot down we
gotta I want to jump to this uh this
story from timcast.com jury rules Trump
committed battery and defamed E Gene
Carroll former president calls verdict a
disgrace a jury has ruled that former
president Donald Trump committed battery
on E Gene Carroll in 1996 and later
defamed her careless claimed Trump raped
her in a Bergdorf Goodman dressing room
in New York City quote I'm here because
Donald Trump raped me and when I wrote
about he said it didn't happen Carol
testified Trump did not testify or all
any Witnesses the case the jury ruled
that Trump did not rape Carol but that
he is liable for sexual abuse he has now
been ordered to pay her five million
dollars in Damages in the civil case
there are no criminal charges Carol went
public blah blah blah this is a crazy
story
Trump said I have absolutely no idea who
this woman is this vert is a disgrace a
continuation of the greatest Witch Hunt
of all time
how is how does something like this
happen it's been 30 some odd years and
now Trump's got to pay five million
dollars what evidence did they have I
guess they must have had something right
did she wear a blue dress or something I
mean I don't know Trump Trump's not
doing himself any favors because
apparently in the deposition he said
something like he he told the lawyer
questioning him that she wasn't hot
enough for him did you guys do that
he plays at the base no matter what man
it was awesome he said something like
she's not really my type and quite
frankly neither are you you didn't
you're not doing yourself
I think a jury responds when they hear
that Snickers personally I I chuckle I
think they chuckle a New York jury yeah
he's like he's like oh should I not have
said that they had any crowd
I just don't know like did she have like
actual evidence a jury of six men and
three men awarded her five million
dollars Trump called it a disgrace
what's uh what what is the what is the
evidence I suppose that they saw that
they felt that warranted Trump having to
pay
they said uh former magazine writer was
abused by Trump nearly 30 years ago the
jury did not find that he raped her as
uh as she had long claimed the jury
returning the verdict right after 3 pm
found Trump is running to regain his
president
Mr Trump's lawyers called No Witnesses
he never appeared at the trial to hear
Miss Carroll who had sued him last year
so maybe that's it it's it's just
because he didn't defend himself that
they were just like okay I guess default
maybe I don't know
she walked to the courthouse grinning
from ear to ear this is crazy to me sure
she did it's absolutely I think I think
I saw that the the judge would not allow
him or his defense to post evidence uh
in for their defense online too so he's
like gagged
I'd be curious to see so the other thing
that that popped up was uh was this
story here because apparently I'm just
in the news all the time Donald Trump's
trial juror fan of right-wing
provocateur Tim cool what website is
this see this is the kind of Creedence
that would be in this jury yeah
they say um where where do we have this
um
a security guard 31 from the Bronx that
he got his news and information from
podcasts he particularly listened to one
by Tim Poole a controversial right wing
comment well at least at least unheard
called me uh a Centrist but I'm I'm
curious for you know this this uh is an
international article because it says it
was May 10th so but I'm curious somebody
who watches this show must have seen
some pretty damning evidence if they're
going to convict Trump right
what do you I don't know what do you
guys think I I was not paying that close
of attention to that trial I heard a
little bit about it today but I didn't
get a chance to look into the verdict
why they see uh I want to be did you
like sniff his fingers is there a video
of it I just don't understand how could
you have evidence it's this long yeah of
something like that happening they're
like well it didn't happen but Trump's
got to pay her anyway yes I mean like
correct me if I'm wrong but like
wouldn't wouldn't the evidence be
everywhere now then wouldn't something
be out there I would have leaked
something if they love talking about him
so I think a lady said Trump did a thing
and they're like okay pay her I think
that's what happened so then when I hear
that like one of the jurors was a fan
I'm like what
he had to have seen something right you
know I just I just can't believe that
somebody would watch this show would be
like I don't need evidence I will
convict I will I will I will uh agree
it's not conviction I guess you know I
will sound liable find Trump liable
there you go
yeah that's funny that he paid five
million dollars to use that line which
one
um
You probably thought it was funny it's
like I'll pay 5 million to say that we
all we all enjoyed it I guess they say
that um Mr takapina clashed the judge
seeking a mistrial on pervasive unfair
and prejudicial hearing rulings based in
part on what he described as the judge
in properly sustaining objections by
Miss Carroll's lawyers who argued that
his questions were argumentative at one
point judge Kaplan quoted the definition
of an argumentative question from
Black's Law Dictionary reading it aloud
to Mr takopina I just I I just I can't I
don't believe it
someone said that you only need six
jurors to find the person guilty in a
Civil Trial I don't know at all and I'm
just seeing something that someone was
saying on the internet I don't know man
I just think all of this is fake I think
there's just gonna be a Non-Stop circus
around him through the entire election
cycle to kind of to have everyone
looking at these different things uh and
to distract away from anything that he
might have to say about you know the the
the nonsense I I think this country is
already fallen off a cliff right we had
that story earlier about the the border
crossings 26 000 apprehensions and the
Biden admins like just released them to
the streets so they're just gonna
release a whole bunch of they're
basically saying there's no border
anymore and I'm not exaggerating yeah
they said that title 42 ends they will
enter this country and they will be
released which means
it's a free-for-all so I see that I'm
kind of just it's hard for me to get
enthused by any of this news where I'm
just sitting here thinking like we are
free falling so with stuff like this I
think people need to I think you're
right I think we're over the cliff and
we need to give up on on any kind of
political solution from the the federal
level however the states and the
localities have a lot of decision-making
Authority Under the 10th Amendment a lot
and I think that's really got to be the
political thing that is embraced this
concept of nullification you know
there's absolutely no reason there's
absolutely no reason that states can't
set their own immigration policies you
know that's not in article one section
eight of the Constitution they have
every bit of authority to do that and
basically well not basically everything
that's not listed explicitly in article
one section eight of the Constitution is
is up for this kind of movement so I
really think that that that's what's got
to happen is we've got to realign
politics with culture closer to the
localities in these states and then
that's who was always meant to be making
the majority of decisions anyway radical
decentralization that's what has to
happen but not just that in theory it
was given to us by the founders that
power was there uh uh and and debated
heavily uh you know for the states and
the localities to have this and that is
my opinion what has to happen is we have
got to
bring the sovereignty back down as close
to the individual as possible good no I
just want to ask you I hear you but what
would that look like at a state level
how would that operate if states were
having more strict immigration laws or
enforcing them in a way that the federal
government wasn't
they would I mean they they would have
whatever authorities and and uh
resources at their disposal so like the
the Texas National Guard yeah they could
they could authorize that to do what
they want because why if Texas being a
Border Town uh and is affected the most
why shouldn't they have the most say or
why shouldn't they do it as they see fit
when they're being essentially made to
Stand Down by the feds when they have no
authority to do that in the first place
yeah that's an interesting point I I
hear you now look I'm all about like
states rights uh and having the states
step in especially when the federal
government is failing to do their Duty
uh I I hope something like that could
work I'm a little worried though just
about
how we'd be able to pull that off
especially with budgets I mean yeah no
it's being no and I agree with you that
the states at some point have to do
something that the federal government
isn't going to step in and do anything
so we're definitely on the same page
there I'm just a little worried about
how effective it's going to be well they
I get encouraged by it because anything
almost anything that's good that happens
happens at this level like you see
States uh like legalizing gold and or
gold and silver is legal tender you know
you see States like there was just a
major victory for the defend the guard
Bill uh in the senate in Arizona yeah
you see constitutional carry at the
state level like you see these different
things that happen and that's I mean
what wins like that could you say have
happened in the federal level in the
past five years none and that's the
point the the thing is the
infrastructure that we're the the
infrastructure I would say well but
that's judicial but still I would agree
with that yeah yeah I would agree with
that the things that we're discussing
right now are all the infrastructure is
all there it's it's the way that our
government set up currently so it's
really just States taking the authority
that they have you know Governors
getting some balls and state
legislatures getting some balls and
doing things that they decide are good
for their states whether it be Abbott in
Texas or whether it be you know DeSantis
these are Governors that are doing
things that help their states and other
Governors should follow suit and here's
the thing it's not just the states the
localities have this Authority and and
and so when the localities start to
embrace this that starts to set the tone
for the culture in the state or the
conversation in the state to make a move
at the state and what we're describing
is actually what the mises caucus is all
about like that's that we're calling it
project decentralized Revolution we're
recruiting people to run for a city
council mayor School Board Sheriff judge
to to run for these types of offices
where you can nullify the federal
government uh from that local level for
the specific purpose to nullify the
federal government uh at that level
that's what we're all about we know that
we're not winning governor and Senate
you know like we're we're realistic
stick but this is what in my opinion has
to be done and it it kind of brings
together both the political solution and
the cultural solution because culture is
something that emerges from the ground
up it's not something they're trying to
bring it down from the top but that it's
not organic it's not real so by bringing
the community together at that local
level to make these decisions and
insulate ourselves from the insanity of
the Feds that I think is the thing that
in time can generate the broader
conversations what's the biggest
resistance you would find to something
like that just maybe like one example of
the biggest resistance you would find
and how you'd face that the cult
mentality that seeks power in the will
to dominate
it is the will to dominate because the
the thing the thing that people that are
against libertarian ideals tend to
object to even if they don't say it is
they can't do things that they want to
do that will negatively affect other
people right they can't implement this
policy or implement this this project
and the reason is because it'll affect
other people and so people don't want to
vote libertarian if they can't use the
government to push other people around
whether it be push other people around
by getting uh money from the government
and and having funding whatever their
pet project is or maybe it's make sure
that this person doesn't do a drug that
I don't like or doesn't have a lifestyle
that I don't like the the will to
dominate libido dominante is something
that is ingrained in a significant
portion of humans probably most humans
and it's a very small portion of people
that are like I really am A Live and Let
Live person and if it wasn't for that
fact that it is a very small portion you
would see more libertarian policies
actually in the world because everyone
says as their libertarian everyone says
no I don't wanna you know I'm a Live and
Let Live kind of guy until it comes down
to actually voting as if you're a
live-in let live kind of guy and I just
want to plug one resource on this front
the guys over at the 10th Amendment
Center Michael bold and Mike maharry uh
and the 10th amendmentcenter.com they
they do this work and they track all of
these notification type of bills that
are happening at the various states
around the country so there already is
that repository and they have sample
legislation on their website that
anybody can start taking to their city
council or to their State Rep to to do
various things from you know a gun
sanctuary where you know the the state
or the locality is going to not uh
comply with federal gun control laws to
the gold and silver repositories to
decriminalization to the Banning of the
warrantless use of surveillance
technology all of this stuff can be done
like once you realize how short of a
list of authority is in Article 1
Section 8 your imagination could run
wild on what you can insulate yourself
from in your community from the feds
I think that if we got rid of party
affiliation on ballots you'd see a lot
of Libertarians in office probably
you'd see a lot less Democrats you'd see
a lot of uh different parties in general
the the closest thing that I can say
that backs that up is that the majority
of Victories for Big L Libertarians are
at the local level and specifically uh
where the state makes it so that local
level races don't have party affiliation
yep what do they say unaffiliated yep
yeah there's a lot of uh local
politicians that we've talked about who
are clearly Democrats but they're listed
as unaffiliated even though they they're
members of the democratic party and they
fundraise with them and things like that
but like you said so I I think we talked
about it before get rid of DNR and L or
whatever just names
and then let the uninformed voters go in
and be confused and vote at random
they'll just check a random box or don't
vote yeah don't know who you're voting
for don't vote you'd see a lot fewer
Democratic celebrities getting on
television saying just go out and vote
this is one of my pet peeves this is one
of my pet peeves right every single time
you see one of these get out and vote
PSAs it is almost always a spokesperson
from the left and it's because they know
the people who are only going out to
vote because a celebrity on their
television told them to don't know
anything and will almost certainly vote
Democrats get out the vote or get out
the vote is always targeting people that
are uninformed about what they're voting
for exactly let me let me give one piece
of pushback here and this is an example
and that maybe this wouldn't work out
um so I remember I was working for
majestore when he was
um uh running for City Council in
Philadelphia now the rules for City
Council in Philadelphia are you have
seven at large positions on the city
council uh and any one party is only
allowed to have five of those spots so
the two spots are reserved for the
minority party
uh and what happened in that race this
was 2019 is that a couple of Democrats
created a fake third party called The
People's party uh and you know so it
wasn't subject to the to the party line
and yet they got pumped with millions of
dollars and almost took all seven spots
they took six so they took the the sixth
spot and almost took the seventh spot
wow
well all right now that's Philadelphia
though yeah which brings me to another
potential solution what about the idea
of I don't know if this I I don't know
about if this would require like a state
Constitutional Convention but when you
think of the county party or not parties
the county uh governments what would
happen if the collective of County
polities came together and essentially
just pushed out the big cities to be
their own self-governing units be like
you know Philadelphia love love the the
stuff that you produce for us don't
really like sharing a government yeah
here in Pennsylvania so we should have a
borders with you but you're saying that
we should build a wall but not on the
southern border just around all of the
Cities
yeah I've definitely 30 feet no doors
yeah and put a dome on top
just forget about it and plug your ears
when you hear yelling I've heard people
uh argue for this right with Washington
DC specifically also with um
with LA uh Chicago as well right
separating from Illinois I I see many
upsides to that I wonder if it's if it's
possible I mean normally I would have
said you know if you asked me a couple
years ago will that ever happened I
would say absolutely not that's crazy
but so many things that I would not have
predicted happening have happened over
the past couple years so it's got to the
point where like I don't know maybe that
is possible we we got this story from
CNN ladies and gentlemen they got him
George Santos charged by Justice
department and Federal Federal probe and
that's it we have no information they
say it's sealed we have no idea why
they're charging him so uh there you go
spokespeople for the Brooklyn news
attorney's office declined to comment
it's a sealed indictment and that's it
this is the uh the guy who I guess they
say lied about everything to get elected
and he was actually a drag queen or
something one of the guys that lied
about everything to get elected one of
one of uh 435
is how they're going to get the house
back just a series of un like sealed
indictments they're gonna start
indicting everybody for fraud being like
you lied to get elected and then just
yeah that's the job description I'm Pro
Santos man that guy lied so much and
then lied in such a spectacularly
hilarious way but how do you know how do
you know he lied okay uh well then I
would be less Pro Santos if he didn't
lie to be honest with you I guess the
deciding factor is the lies there's a
there's this picture of a drag queen in
Brazil and they're like that's him and
I'm like I I don't know that's him like
it's a Dre it's a drag queen wearing a
bunch of makeup in a costume I mean it
might be I don't know whatever makes the
story more hilarious I'm for yeah this
is the thing they do it's like yo if I
if I go online I can find a picture that
looks like Phil and then be like here's
Phil riding a giraffe in you know Africa
or whatever people kind of look like him
and
and then every every all the other
stories they're like is it true you
didn't actually do this thing or that
thing and I'm like look I don't know
what he did or did live and I'm just
saying like if someone says 20 years ago
if I can I was like 20 years ago I was
riding my bike and I did a a bar Spin
and then you're like that's a lie Tim
doesn't ride bikes you know how do you
know I didn't do it how do you how do
you verify these things
you know what I mean that guy is
supposed to be a Brazilian crossdresser
yeah
now they got pretty convincing ladyboys
over there that guy wouldn't cut make
the car I don't know they all claimed
that he was I looked up look I got the
Snopes article to fact check it and I'm
not seeing a conclusive answer in the
Snopes article
was red George San Jose drag queen in
Brazil and they don't actually say they
don't tell you
the one time we needed the most they
disappeared
where's the fact check at the bottom
look at this they're claiming this is it
like what
there's actually there's a better
picture of him I I urge to be no well
not in the Snopes article even Snopes
couldn't confirm it
YouTube video oh wait hold on let me see
New York betcha he drinks Bud Light
Maybe
speaking of uh pictures that look kind
of like me there's a kid that actually
put up a picture of someone that he
thought looked like me he's like this
isn't philibonti but it made me remember
how much I hate filibonti so you're
right there are plenty of pictures out
there where someone will remind someone
of someone else enough
or like Clint and uh Fred Durst oh yeah
so this is this is the picture
they're saying performa Eula rochards
provided so you know this image of a
person she claims is George Santos I
hope it's real I I just don't think it's
him
that does not look like the fresh maker
to me I don't know
I don't know man I want to believe we
may be but the nose the nose is
different
he's got a a round nose this one's got
you know the nose is a little wider at
the base
maybe I just don't believe it could you
imagine and look at the lips
his lips are way different that's crazy
and he denies it strongly To None claims
that he once performed the most recent
obsession with the media claiming I'm a
drag queen of performed as a drag queen
it's categorically false and they just
go with it and then people just claim
it's true this is I just think it's nuts
you can't take a picture of somebody and
be like that's him and you're like how
do I how do I know that so wait a minute
is he being indicted for being a
Brazilian crossdresser no we don't know
why he's being indicted but people need
to understand this too I've anybody
who's ever seen a celebrity you know
walking down the street you're like is
that is that him I can't tell because
when they're doing movies or doing TV
shows the angles are all different one
of the biggest tricks in media that
confuses people is that cameras are
typically held at a at uh like chest
height like right below your rib cage
and so this makes everybody look really
tall so when you're watching a TV show
men and women look tall because the
perspective you have is looking up at
them yeah then you meet him in real life
and you're like this dude's very short
women especially they film women at from
a low angle and it makes them look like
they're tall and then you meet them in
real life and like this lady's five foot
tall so that's what happens a lot of
these these politicians too you meet him
in your back I didn't realize so I don't
know why do you like this guy Phil what
about just because he he lied his way
into Congress then for no other reason
just because you like every politician
how that separates him he's so blatantly
lied like he told people that he was
Jewish he like someone's like he was
telling people that he had like a
grandmother that died in the Holocaust
and then he came back and said no no I
never said that I said that I am Jewish
I'm kind of and now all sorts of that
was good all sorts of really really
really big Whoppers like absurd Whoppers
that make it all right you're really
putting it on you gotta be a Pocahontas
fan then yeah no remember remember when
that lady claimed that Kavanaugh was had
was gang raping women in college yes and
they all just run the story and they
believe it and not only well with that
story not only do they not have evidence
the evidence actually pointed in the
opposite direction like there were
people who were supposed who were at the
party where this supposedly occurred
saying that like well that was the first
story line up the first story was when
she claimed that he penned her to a bat
or something and then rolled around but
like even that story that she told I'm
like so wait she was at a party and she
was upstairs with and there were two
guys and he threw her on the bed and
jumped on her and then the other guy
jumped on him and they rolled around
laughing and giggling and she was and
that's her that's her like rape story
that that was the story I guess he like
jumped on the bed and then the friend
John I thought I don't remember I
thought I I thought she accused him of
something pretty serious no I just
remembered that the evidence of the
eyewitness testimony of people who were
actually there at the event did not
corroborate her story the first so that
was I think that was sweat Nick or
whatever that was uh first you had uh
Christine blasey Ford and she was like I
was at a party we went upstairs he
jumped on me on the bed and held me down
then his friend jumped on him and then
knocked him over and then they rolled
around and then I left but none of the
people at that party remember him being
here there even her friends like I don't
know what she's talking about that never
happened and then she lied about
everything she lied about she's like I'm
scared to travel and they're like you've
gone on vacation several times on planes
and she's like oh it's like I have to
have two doors to my house so scared and
they're like you Airbnb that one like
you're you're renting it out it's just
none of it was true well yeah and then
it was the other woman who claimed at a
party Brett Kavanaugh would and and the
boys would have uh gang bangs where they
would kidnap a woman and lock her in a
room and then line up outside the door
and take turns
Christ like these things don't happen
these people just make things up and
then they believe it
that's modern politics for you yeah and
then the BBC is like we believe it's
true and Tim pool's wrong do you think
it's starting to happen where we don't
believe it though because absolutely
because like like take the Trump story
does it really feel like there's like
momentum behind that story like like
like you were saying that you you're not
even following it you're on this show
every day like yeah it doesn't I I feel
like it's worn out like I I like the
whole wild claims thing that's why I'm
I'm saying like it's getting really hard
to care to be honest like we're in free
fall there's no Southern border the
economy is imploding and then this this
stuff I'm just kind of like look
culturally I think people have just said
shut your mouths to the Psychopaths they
just shut up don't I hear it and then
what can you really do as the economy is
crumbling
get a cities
you know pretty much it's the Land of
Confusion there's no wild how we're
talking about some some pretty heinous
stuff and
some some of it's like I don't know if I
really care I don't know if I can follow
along with all of it I don't know how
much of it I actually believe it's
burnout man and it's every single day
it's it's several stories every single
day that you would imagine are huge but
now it's just like it's just too much I
don't know if I even care anymore right
yeah that's that's the collapse and yeah
and they they almost never pay any kind
of price for lying right I mean in the
case of Sandman you know he was able to
sue him and then they settled out uh out
of court and I think some say that
written houses launched some lawsuits
and potentially he'll get some money out
of them but for the most part they just
lie constantly and they basically never
pay any price for it deferred liability
it's like these these articles and stuff
like that if you word it in such a way
well it's actually even what Tucker was
even saying like you can say something
that could hold up a lawyer would sign
off on it but it's really misleading
it's not really pointing it in the right
direction and he could have given a
better example you know it's like if I
said a guy was arrested you know in
charge of the crime but unjustly you
might say okay that that may be true we
don't know but then if I if I if I were
to Omit that he was arrested six times
previously for the same crime now I'm
misleading you there's better examples
the example I like to give is quotes
they do this all the time oh yeah I like
when they when they attributed Sheamus's
statement to Ian see Ian yeah Jezebel
did that they literally took a statement
right from me one of my greatest hits a
based and red pilled quote about how
horrible and stupid no fault divorce is
and they gave it to Ian Crossland
here's a better way to explain how the
media lies Sheamus will say I once heard
Phil Labonte claim that he prefers
chocolate ice cream over strawberry all
right he said filibonti said to me I
like chocolate ice cream more than I
like strawberry ice cream they would
then say Sheamus Coughlin said quote I
like because you did say those words it
is literally true and if you sued you
wouldn't win because it'd be like
Sheamus literally said those words we
quoted him even though the context was
it was someone else you were repeating
exactly I mean they're using their
language to communicate a non-truth
which is lying but you're right that in
a literal sense technically they can say
factual but not true magazines have been
doing that like what was there was this
one and I might have just heard this as
an example but it was like Michael
Jackson and Faye Dunaway get married
they did but not to each other
so let's let's look for a celebrity who
just got married let me let me let me
see if I can do a quick Google search um
and then use mid-journey to put their
pictures together
oh my goodness so we just celebrity
weddings of 2023 seven hours ago who got
who got married all right so I got this
article and uh this one's gonna be fun
um see ya
got married
okay and also Lucas I don't know who
those people are so okay so Sia right
you know you know Sia right musician
singing from the show swing from the
chandelier let's just try and find um
Simone biles
well there we go see ya and Simone biles
have gotten married
I like it yeah you believe it that's Sia
Sia and Simone biles got married some
mighty fine reporting there too I try to
be a white pillar and I don't want to
say that there's no consequences to them
lying you know what I think the
consequence of them lying are the
success of this show the success that
Tucker Carlson is about to have outside
of the notes yeah yeah like the success
that Tucker Carlson's about to have
outside of the system the success of Joe
Rogan and Patrick Bet David and Dave
Smith and and all of this stuff and I
think the other cost is kind of the
conversation that we're having right now
like yeah I don't believe that rape
story yeah yeah like here we go well
Abigail Breslin and Buzz Aldrin got
married
like those are factual statements but I
never said to each other so just to
respond to what you're saying I totally
agree with that and I think the fact
that there's real competition is a
massive white pill my point about them
not facing consequences is that there's
no consequence from within their own
structure so they don't have any
incentive to tell the truth in their own
institution but you're correct that if
you look outside of the institution uh
there are very good reasons why they
should start telling the truth about
things if they want to be successful but
they're more interested in promoting
their narrative than they are and
they're completely trapped within their
dying model and their dying Paradigm
because like what was it like maybe six
months ago that CNN tried to do that um
CNN plus about a year ago now yeah
actually time flies it was I think it
was a little over a year ago right but
in CNN it it crashed and burned like
instantly yeah it was so bad I saw these
beautiful board in LA and then it was
just gone
they had to sell it what that seems like
to me is short-term gain over long-term
gain yeah like these institutions
they'll still use these old tricks
because there's short-term gain in it it
worked on the Boomers but us Wiley
Millennials right uh time preference we
love Hopper you need a better mousetrap
there propagandus
so who did uh George Santos just marry
then yeah we got to figure that out well
he if they have to at least get married
to somebody for me to claim they got
married yeah that's true you know so it
is what it is but Buzz Aldrin got
married so basically anybody right now
guys listening if anybody you know gets
married if like if you have like a
friend named you know Sarah Smith you
bet you know Sarah Smith and Buzz Aldrin
got married and they're like what
to Buzz Aldrin and be like huh unless I
got married not to each other you can
just say those things now that's how the
media works that's a good one by the way
it is that's a great one yeah we should
there's other examples like that that
you could just pair up like you know
these these two things happened in the
same year or on the same day and you'd
somehow merge them together yeah like we
could say something like um Tucker
Carlson announced his new show on
Twitter shortly after Vladimir Putin
places nuclear weapons in southern
Belarus it's like as if to imply they're
related or something true story yeah
and you're like what are those things
have to do with each other well it's you
know well you got to read the rest of
the article
well you know after Tucker heard about
this he said I got to get out I got to
get back on the air and I gotta talk
about this you know and and there you go
I mean that is the implication with
Tucker and Elon though they had a
meeting yeah after the meeting he's like
hey I'm doing a show on Twitter and the
neon's like we don't have a contract
yeah so it's like there's the real
inference you know how many interviews
did Tucker do since he left because I
knew he was just on Michael Knowles
right did he do know no I don't think he
did any any show
I could have sworn I saw a piece with
him on Michael Knowles's show maybe it
was before the whole thing went down but
yeah I don't know
because he was talking about building
seven
Tucker was and he was saying how like
you can talk about Flat Earth because no
one will believe you but ask some
questions about building seven and
you'll get fired for that that was on
Michael Knowles wow
I don't know
I don't think so no I don't think Tucker
did an interview with anybody yet oh you
got deep faked no because uh I mean it
could be wrong but my understanding was
that um he's he still works for Fox News
he is still a contracted employee of Fox
News he he so he's still it's no
different than when he when he had a
show they just took his show away
interesting that's gonna bug me I don't
know what what are people saying in the
in the chat did he they're saying it was
Tulsi gabbard that's what he did a show
on Tulsi gabbard that would make sense I
mean they're friends right but I saw
Michael Knowles's face responding and
reacting to him maybe he's got a clip
and yeah yeah he could clip that yeah
yeah okay maybe yeah I'd imagine so so
Tucker uh
appeared she did a show with wait I saw
that on YouTube I swear I saw that
something the other day that she had
Tucker Carlson on her show I think
something like that yeah uh I don't know
no I think people are wrong this looks
like old clips from Fox News she put on
her channel uh okay yeah
no idea yeah Tucker didn't do an
interview with Michael Knowles he did it
with Tulsi gabbard
but where did they do it because on
tulsi's channel I don't see it
is it here what am I looking at I saw
the I saw a clip from him but I'm not
sure where where she posted it that's
what I thought I think
no idea I see stuff from like two or
three weeks ago with Tugger
he was on redacted what is redacted uh I
think people are saying also it was on
milk boys too
um Trump was on nope boys a while ago as
well I think that might I think might be
right I think basically Tucker was on
every single show just name a show he
was on it it's uh Schrodinger's Tucker
Carlson yeah
what's that oh that's the full sign
podcast right
yes snoke boys is full send by the way
uh the Trump one is pretty oh yeah it
looks like they someone there's
did they have Tucker Carlson that was a
month ago
uh yes yeah so these are these are old
like wood after
the the firing is is the question did it
happen you know what I mean yeah yeah
yeah no idea
no idea but um I don't know man
it's just it's it really is sometimes I
wake up and this morning I see the story
about the borders completely open just
just gone and I'm like but it's been
gone you know what I mean like have we
do we really believe there was anything
going on with the Border but Tim hold on
have you considered that a nation
fulfilling its primary definitional duty
of protecting the Border uh is mean
one more time have you considered that a
nation fulfilling the most basic duty of
a Nation or government by protecting its
border is mean it's very mean yeah it
triggers me yeah yeah have you
considered that you're bad
the fact that the federal government has
three
like real jobs provide Courts for
redressive grievance
um
protect the borders and uh you know
prevent uh protect the the rights of the
citizens and stop Mr I'm shocked at this
blue pilledness that you think that the
stated purpose is actually there behind
the goal and they can't even protect the
borders yeah yeah it's it's ridiculous
and they intentional they used to yeah
Obama is the porter-in-chief remember
but didn't they change the definition of
deportation right before he took office
it made it seem like you deported more
than he actually did they've changed the
definition of everything else yeah well
because I think it used to be you
actually had to round someone up and
send them out of the country for it to
be considered a deportation but then
under Obama what they said was people
who were sent away who came to the
border and were sent back were counted
as deportations oh really yeah sounds
like something you'd do yeah he also set
up those concentration camps that AOC
was so concerned about cages but didn't
care until Donald Trump became president
yeah it most of the arguments that you
see in politics are are just fallacies
created to attack their opponents the
political opponents more so than uh
anything of substance very rarely do you
have politicians that are actually
talking about things or substance and
that's something that Tucker Carlson
talks about a lot he'd made he'd made a
remark that I think in the last video
that he put up that the most important
things that you can talk about like War
the economy etc those are things you're
not really allowed to have any kind of
dissenting opinion on and if you do then
you get things like booted out of your
job or whatever and so you know back to
the the fact that Tucker's going on to
Twitter I think again it reaffirms that
to me this is a really good thing you've
got Elon Musk who ostensibly is looking
to have the most honest platform out
there I mean Community notes does it all
the time they're the community notes
will tell you if an ad is bsing you know
you can get you can get a a community
known on advertisements so
even if you don't like Tucker Carlson or
even if you don't like Elon Musk Elon
Musk or Tucker Carlson being on Twitter
with Community notes means if Tucker
Carlson lies or tells something that
isn't true
it can be refuted with with uh Community
notes the left thinking that that's a
bad thing or the left knot and mass
trying to get on to Twitter to make sure
that they're able to have a voice it'll
it'll be
a bad thing for the left
if they don't come to Twitter and and
refute the things that Tucker says
um and as far as I'm concerned fine
because generally I find myself agreeing
with Tucker Carlson most of the time
um and I have a significant uh
we'll call it distaste for the far left
but you know walk away and and let us go
ahead and have the floor and and
control the narrative I don't mind that
at all yeah
so there's this one of the articles that
we pulled up from the Free Beacon
apparently people think that George
Santos and Gretchen Whitmer are the same
person
so that that's one you know
yeah George Santos in drag George Santos
Gretchen Whitmer they're all the same
person dude listen dude she should be
indicted here's the thing the Deep fake
thing is going to make this so much
easier a few years ago there was a
picture that went viral of uh Richard
Dawkins and uh who's the one who played
the girl in Harry Potter
there's a picture that went viral of
Richard Dawkins and Emma Watson side by
side where their faces look very very
similar it looks like they're they're
almost identical uh but what someone
actually did was slightly manipulated
both of their faces so that they looked
more similar to each other but for a
while people were going oh my gosh Emma
Watson and Richard Dawkins look so
similar that's going to be really easy
to pull off with AI people are going to
start doing that and conflating a
picture of one person with a picture of
another person or just generating
completely fake images of of people at
like drag shows or whatever I'm gonna
get fact checked by Snopes they're gonna
say did Donald Trump run through DC with
Hedgehog false Tim pool is fake news you
know did Donald Trump team up with
signed Hedgehog false Tim pool AI
generated that picture it's not like the
Hedgehog is not real at some point the
only way people are gonna be able to
know something as real as if it came
from your account right and even then
you could be lying yeah yeah or someone
could make a fake account that looks
just like yours and then by verification
or something that begs the question of
in the AI space is there any kind of
like corresponding growth in detection
for what is AI because there's some real
dark side to all of this stuff too like
imagine imagine you know you're married
and then all of a sudden there's deep
fake porn of you quote unquote cheating
on your wife you know I mean that could
get real crazy real fast or imagine a
guy cheats and his wife and then the
wife finds video and he's like honey
that's a that's a defect that's not real
it's gonna be so easy to Gaslight people
and Sai stuff girls like that's no that
Chad GPT made that but that's what I'm
saying is there any kind of like uh
corresponding technology where it's like
this was AI generated you know I'm sure
there will be aisle I think there might
be AIS that we'll be able to tell you I
but I don't know man we're getting
dangerously close to that point where
you can make fake historical photographs
that look real you know and slightly
alternates to play that you're like
that's a people will think it's the real
photo so take a picture of Donald Trump
doing something and then alter it in
such a way that it's a little bit worse
than it really was Everybody Eats it up
and you were even saying that the
scariest thing isn't going like Hog Wild
on the Deep fake it's much more about
changing one word yeah slightly changing
the context or making it sound like they
used a derogatory term in the midst of a
speech that they actually gave because
then everyone's going to be like we know
the speech happened but which one's the
real one if you do a fake video of like
Donald Trump punching a baby No One
Believes it yeah Donald Trump running
with Sonic the Hedgehog in DC some
people might fall I get that yeah I
believe that yeah
he was freaking out but that well so you
show me the one where they were shaking
hands and I was almost like that was
real but then I noticed Sonic wasn't
wearing any gloves and I was like Sonic
always fingernails yeah I was like
that's fake but that that one did almost
you did almost get me
but then someone's gonna make a picture
of of Donald Trump yelling or something
and people will think it's real or like
you said like changing a minor word here
and there with the uh the audio
technology or the voice yeah like voice
synthesizers the very fine people hoax
yeah they'll change him saying and I'm
not talking about the white nationalists
or the neo-nazis because they should be
condemned totally they'll change it to
him saying because some of them should
be condemned totally so that they can be
like I know that's what you're talking
about I did hear it and he said some of
them and you'll say no we said they and
then they'll play the clip and you'll
pick which one's the real one and they
both look identical they both say CBS
and then they're going to be like I know
Trump is bad he said some of them yeah I
know he did not come out and praise them
that's that's crazy but he did say some
of them because he thought some were
okay well also even with uh just the way
they decide to parse out the grammar of
it when he said they're not sending
their best we've talked about this in
the show before they're not sending
their best they're sending their what
did he say criminals robbers Etc they're
murderers and then they're rapists as in
clearly they are sending their rapists
but they translate it as they are
rapists Trump said Mexicans are rapists
like what do you think like yes he gave
a campaign speech and he's like do you
know what I think of all Mexicans
thing yeah the most ludicrous thing in
the world
all right we're gonna go to Super Chat
so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to the channel share the show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
by clicking that join us button one of
the members on the uncensored show
coming up for you at 10 10 p.m eastern
time you don't want to miss it it's
gonna be a lot of fun and if you are a
member you can submit questions and even
call into the show and talk to us and
our guests but now we will slowly and
calmly
read your super chats
drive by commenter says don't know if
you guys discussed this but researchers
are able to use MRIs with generative AI
to read people's Thoughts with 82
accuracy what but repeat that we're
gonna put Sheamus in that machine yeah
and then we're gonna go in the mic
Sheamus Pop-Tart
and then they're gonna be like he's he's
thinking about watermelons so wait a
minute it does what with 82 accuracy
reads your mind what yeah what kind of
image you're This is Gonna Save looking
at It's Gonna Save so many relationships
where do you want where do you want to
eat honey and then you just put the AI
on her head and it's like oh Denny's
okay they're gonna have to miniaturize
MRIs so that way you can actually have
it in the car or something like that
it'll send a text to your phone of the
image that she's thinking right it's
scary to think that the intelligence
applications of all of this stuff have
probably been plotted out for years yeah
oh that's a good point yeah they already
know exactly how they're going to use
this to screw us yeah the intelligence
applications were the inspiration to
start the research in the first place oh
yeah all this converges on sentient
World simulation look at oh God
all right we'll look that up I'm looking
Brett Chet says shout out to chicken
City Buck Cluckers
the other night I noticed the light was
on and I went out and looked and some of
the chickens were outside like in the in
the outer area
sleeping and I'm like they didn't why
didn't they go inside
there's a little door that opens the Sun
and then goes down at Sunset and the
chickens they go home but these chickens
they didn't go home
why
no idea anyway
where are we at
Tuma says to the guest is there other
branches of the caucus in other states
oh yeah so there's
um a 50-state apparatus we have 250
State organizers uh and thousands of
volunteers under us and uh so if you
were to go to take humanaction.com and
sign up uh they would contact you and
get you involved
right on
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim once the
right stops giving a an ish what the
freak cult says or thinks about them
Victory will come much faster let them
ruin themselves a wise beanie Man beanie
man once said don't know don't care
I I do say that I just said it Soleil
cucumber lime says let's F and go Maga
2024 7.
7 I think that picture of trump shaking
hands inside the Hedgehog is the energy
we need for 2024.
I made that image because Sheamus
suggested a different image that my
journey wouldn't let me make because it
broke its rules no you we dude we made
we made so many insane images over the
weekend we were we yeah and then Sheamus
suggested one and I typed it in and said
you have Brett you are I don't remember
which one well yeah I would remind you
because I genuinely don't remember which
one it's not something I could probably
probably be appropriate for families
well Sheamus had a dirty mind he was
like do this one no I said like I'm like
okay no no we did well you did pregnant
Donald Trump and then I was like Duke
right hey so she did pregnant Trump and
he had a pregnant Trump I was like I was
dressed I was like I was like do
pregnant Trump and like Sonic is the dad
standing next to him or something like
that
um and it was I don't remember the
because the day is that the one I tried
no that one worked and all it did was
make a picture of trump as Sonic
[Laughter]
morbidly obese Joe Biden 700 feet tall
crushing New York City and it made it
into this big massive Joe Biden just
crushing buildings there was this is
there was no reason for our minds to
have access to this technology like we
were coming up with some absurd nonsense
I'll mention I'll mention the members
only exactly what Sheamus suggested I do
and it told me it broke the rules
I don't even remember what it was and
then what we're going to talk about for
the members only is we have this uh
leftist anti-police protester was going
to an anti-police protest and was killed
I I think I think that's what the story
was she died in a robbery or something
like that it's a tragic story but it's
like you know we gotta address why
probably probably shouldn't get rid of
the police you know like maybe maybe
reform and stuff like that but you know
but uh but we'll mention the members
only exactly what Sheamus recommended I
search for and why it didn't work
all right Dave says Mike can you speak
to what's happening in Michigan's
libertarian party the fraudulent board
continues to raise funds and purport to
be legitimate despite the lnc statement
of the contrary God this is getting into
uh inside baseball but um
to set the table uh it seems to me that
the effect that politics has on The
Human Condition exists uh everywhere uh
and so there were some people who were
extremely extremely angry uh and upset
that we took the libertarian party over
uh to the point where they were willing
to sabotage the party or their state
parties on the way out and uh long story
short
um without getting all the boring
details the libertarian party of
Michigan
um
held a convention that was against its
rules to try to displace our leadership
um and then uh continued on with that
proclaimed to replace the leadership
didn't
um and then their judicial committee
which is like the court system of the
party ruled that that was not accurate
that that was all invalid they broke the
rules restored the old board uh and
there is now a dispute between these two
boards that's that is the I don't want
to bore everybody short version
Andrew Roland says I would like to see
Twitter at a video platform to compete
with YouTube and Rumble depending on how
the ad Revenue will go could potentially
move a lot of people from YouTube to
Twitter I completely agree I really do
want to see them create a proper video
component to Twitter because I've got
1.6 million followers and I would put my
my videos up on on Twitter you could you
could do it right now
it just doesn't work that well because
the way the feed works you need to be
able to like have a recommended videos
thing or something like that or people
need to start building the habits of
going to their video feed on Twitter
which means Twitter needs to make a
video feed section
Eric Miller says cast Brew Coffee names
Hen House Blend and you should do a keto
creamer called shamer
nice or is it is it Shimmer no shamer
because that's that's my podcast bro
he's like trying to shout me out big
league Drew says Tim if you disagree
with me you're in a cult pool quite to
the opposite good sir my point was if
you went to the public and the public
held a world view that you did not it
was you who was the odd person out not
the public these leftists are all about
making the world a bend for them instead
of them adapting to the world it's the
the peak of hubris to be like everyone
else should change to accommodate my
demands you can't it's impossible is
everyone gonna gonna Bend to the whims
of literally every other person it makes
no sense
we just try to uh
we just try our hardest bpay says 1.5
million Subs times five dollars is 7.5
million dollars per month without being
exclusive to the platform Elon also said
they wouldn't be taking ten dollars for
the first year
how many uh followers does Tucker
Carlson have
good question what's uh he's got seven
million
Tucker Carlson has seven million
followers I imagine he'll be making a
couple million dollars per month not 7.5
but maybe like two
because uh conversion matters and he
should charge more than five bucks
um hosting and stuff is expensive and we
want Tucker to succeed so but but you
know maybe maybe five works for his show
considering volume volume matters if
you've got a hundred followers and you
want to make a living off of your
platform you need those hundred
followers to give you like
you know what maybe 20 or 30 bucks a
month so that you can break even and do
some kind of show
if you have a thousand followers now you
only need 10 bucks per person five bucks
the more followers you have the less the
cheaper it becomes all in all unless
you're trying to build a big Network and
then you've got to pay for all the
bandwidth and hosting and it becomes
more expensive the more followers you
get
but for Tucker doing one show I bet if
he charged five bucks he'd make like two
million dollars per month for sure
bro Cody says Tim did you hear about the
social worker who was ax murdered in
Vermont the idea that social workers are
equipped to handle the mentally ill
running around is a liberal fantasy I
agree
I agree
Omega rasetsu says Tim I cringe every
time you say economic right and left
economics falls in the authoritarian
libertarian access not left right
bottom-up versus top down completely
wrong you are wrong sir wrong
so uh on the libertarian Spectrum you
can have an Arco communist and an
arco-capitalist and people who don't
understand the Spectrum might say like
how can Communists be anarchists
seven people living on a farm who don't
use money for any exchange and have an
expectation amongst each other as a
community on what work is to be done and
how so it's quite literally someone's
like hey I grew some squash would you
like to share it with me I'm going to
give my squash to you and then the other
hippie goes and I did the dishes so that
we could have clean plates when we eat
our squash that's not Capital that is
communal labor works really really well
for small groups and tribes does not
scale then you move to the right and you
get laissez-faire capitalism where the
guy walks the other guy and says I got
squash if you want it it's a dollar a
piece that dollar is a universal trade
medium that I use then they can reinvest
that dollar into you know hiring someone
have them grow more squash et cetera et
cetera in the communal side if you start
going towards the authoritarian Spectrum
you get Stalin where he walks up to you
puts a gun in your mouth and says you
are you are giving me your squash
because we're going to share it with
everybody now strangely how it works
with the authoritarian right doesn't
quite make sense because they don't
necessarily have capitalist systems but
there is still a an argument to be made
for what we associate with the
authoritarian right being Ultra
traditionalist and then to your point
there is a confliction between what we
were determined to be the authoritarian
right it's the odd it's the odd group
out in the entirety of the political
Compass however it's typically typically
because Nazis did use Capital systems
they were quote unquote socialists but
they used Capital exchange kind of like
the Chinese Communists do it's all
there's a lot to go through and it's a
lot more complicated than that but
that's a simple version I don't know if
you wanted anything well basically what
you're describing what the Nazis did was
corporatism and that's what we have
today right um it's it's kind of The
Best of Both Worlds between communism
and capitalism where you still have some
semblance of private ownership you still
have a price system and the price system
is probably the most like but that's not
communism that it's just
authoritarianism right it's
authoritarianism but it's it's not
communism in the sense that it's not
complete government ownership and
control but it's government management
through policy through regulation and
and uh they basically picked the the
corporate overlords who then write the
policy and tip everything and So you
you're off of a free market system the
issue is that people think communism and
the only examples that exist in history
are authoritarian statist communism so
they associate authoritarian overt
control and communism as one thing
whereas you can have 10 there there are
communes in the United States where it's
like a hundred people on a farm and they
all just do a base piece of Labor and
then and then share and they vote people
in they vote people out they exist they
just don't scale up because you can't
have a guy from you know Two Towns over
coming over to me and being like okay
now I get your fruit and you get my wood
and they're like I don't need that there
needs to be some kind of way to do an
exchange and it begs the question of
what exactly is economics
um like the school of thought that I'm
from the the Austrian School would say
that economics is basically just the
observing the observance of uh
uh subjective value judgments in in the
marketplace uh when weighed against like
real world things like scarcity so in
that sense uh
action that is economized of all types
is technically economic it's it's
economic activity and money actually
observed historically uh as as a social
phenomenon to solve the problem that
you're talking about it's called in in
economic theory it's called the double
coincidence of once the whole oh well
you have uh an ax I have eggs we can't
trade um so I have to go to some
intermediary to trade my eggs to get
your ax
um and that that is how gold and silver
became money in the organic sense like
it it wasn't a a government that that
dictated that these things are money
they were just a commonly valued
commodity that uh over time became money
and and so that problem was overcome by
by money and then emerged the price
system Kim lalago in the general chat
says that is not communism Tim communism
is Marxism you're talking about hippie
communes I think you exemplified
perfectly my point if we are talking
about the basic economic structure then
yes I am defining communism and you are
defining a specific historical example
of one guy's right which is not the
general concept so there's a bunch of
different kinds of capitalism right
there's there's capitalism like to
varying degrees when you move left and
right on the political Compass you get
varying degrees of Regulation versus
Freedom laissez-faire capitalism but you
there's there's an upward motion as well
so like in the middle you have a basic
thing like the the libertarian middle
would kind of be like we live in a farm
we all agree there's a chore rotation
however if somebody wants a specific
task done then we trade for it if you go
all the way to the hippie commune left
everyone's just like we agree you can
use whatever you want I don't think that
scales properly if you go all the way to
the right that everyone's just trading
and exchanging value which tends to work
very very well in the long run that
doesn't mean that all forms of communal
living are authoritarian because there
there are there are communes in the
United States there's one example I was
reading about 100 people live there 100
people and it is a commune and they have
like a board that votes on when people
can come in and go out and they all
agree the system works and they'll get
along but it's usually like people come
and live there for a year or two and
then leave so
but see what happens is people read
about history and there's one historical
example of communism because it never
works at scale and it's statist
authoritarianism but don't confuse an
authoritarian system with the economic
concept of communal
function like communal economics
all right where are we at
yes man says has anyone ever been far
enough has decided to use even go wants
to do more to do look more like there's
an old meme I wonder yeah it's an old
meme but it checks out Rudy cassone says
Tucker was a traditional libertarian
that's why he backed Ron Paul back in
the day you're probably too young to
remember that
I knew that he was a traditional
libertarian okay he's talked about it
hasn't he
oh yeah I think it was associated with
Cato at one point but there
they're the dark side of the libertarian
Phil dude bro says so whose nickname is
the Hedgehog and who is going to do
battle with hint his name is also Ron
what would what would Trump call Sonic
the Hedgehog if he was debating him oh
how would he insult him yeah
that's a really tough one the the person
is making a reference to a porn star ah
Ron Jeremy is his nickname is the
Hedgehog oh nice he's going to jail
isn't he I believe so yeah
Immortal Legend says pertaining to Keith
Olbermann it must suck to be a
propagandist and be terrible at that job
but bro you had one job
that dude's very unwell he's he is
absolutely hysterical about like when he
tweets and stuff it's not reasonable and
chill it is just
spazzing out yeah
kind of wild to watch yeah Kane Abel
says Tim they really do hate you I would
not be surprised if you're on the FBI's
top 10 list of enemies of the state well
I guess we know what happened when you
do not show up for work I don't know
about that I don't think they hate me I
think they they half like the show they
hate you they fear you they hate you I
think they really don't like no one at
school likes you they all hate you well
you know like the FBI came over and they
were like hey we we're cool dude it's
just Shameless man you brought him back
and I was like are you serious yeah did
you stand the CIA showed up did you say
they were like oh the FBI's here and
then they were like yeah we're here too
and the CIA guy goes like it's Sheamus
isn't it like yeah we're here no no
first of all they're not friends I know
their story isn't true because they
don't like each other they don't like
each other yeah they're both like you
don't like Sheamus either and it's like
well we have that in common yeah that's
fair honestly that that happens has the
has the department of energy showed up
and they were alive oh they really don't
like them right yeah has the Southern
Poverty Law Center declared you a hate
leader yet uh they claimed that uh what
did they say that I was a they I spoke
in Iran at a holocaust deniers
conference because they found an archive
of an Iranian website that's a deep fake
of you I want that's an AI generator
right that I I was a speaker at a
holocaust conference in Iran and I was
just like so wild
yeah and they had to delete it and then
apologize that was hilarious because I
did but did you
I have never been to Iran I am proudly
featured in their hate Watch series oh
wow oh no way yeah Luke they featured
Luke gradkowski a while back did they
make sense yeah I haven't gotten my
wings yet boys you haven't got your
wings and even Media Matters ignored you
no well sore sort of sort of uh Media
Matters published an article based on my
very naughty words and by naughty words
I mean saying marriage is between a man
and a woman
in-game marriage doesn't exist it's an
incoherent concept and they titled it
Tim cast podcast panelists fight
marriage equality to me and the picture
was a view yeah and so people were
sharing it going ah this is why I knew
not to trust him pull he's against gay
marriage and blah blah blah I was like I
was the one who said it right I was the
one who said okay they were making it
sound I know in the article they give me
credit though when Media Matters wrote
the list of Tim cast guests they yeah
they left me out they omitted me it was
funny because I was like I'm worse than
all these people
but you are that's the point that's
actually the really funny actually I
remember a while ago there was also this
um
analysis that was done infamously on
YouTube and how it radicalizes people
and they had a bunch of conservative
channels on there and they put me as
like center right towards moderate and
they took some of my friends who were
like Libertarians uh like and like Lou
Perez from where the internet and put
them in the far right category I was
like wait a minute they're far right and
I'm like center right but the reason the
thing is it's because they have no way
to distinguish between the different
gradients that exist in conservatism
because to them politics is a binary
you're either on my side or you're a
Nazi and then all these people are Nazis
I've only gotten a couple like pokes
from like the left like Media Matters
and stuff like that and they always like
they never mentioned like the band They
call me right wing guy but they never
they never say the guy from All That
Remains you know or whatever they don't
want to they don't want music yeah they
don't want to they don't want people to
know that I'm I'm you know anything
other than a guy that talks on the radio
you're insulated you declared very early
on that you will not give in to fascist
beliefs uh well in 2006 six I am so
ahead of the curve that I was saying
fascism sucks before the commies were
saying fascism sucks before the Zoomer
Connie's not you know that's right the
Southern Yankee says Tim get Mark Dice
on the show Mark Dice has an open invite
I have talked to him many times
um he's a good dude big fan so he can
come on whenever whenever he can that'd
be great it'd be great to have on the
culture War show too we also have uh
we're working on a big project which is
going to be really awesome with the
culture War show expanding it and I'm
really excited for that but we'll give
you more details later on
Rudy cazone says the ancient Romans were
unaware of the lead affecting their
brains from their wine jars today
chemicals in our food cleaning products
Etc are affecting many people's ability
to reason true and I actually think it's
making the the freaking kids trans
because the endocrine disruptors and the
Plastics and all that are affecting
fetal development I don't care what was
in the room and water Marcus Aurelius
had his together yeah he was based
yeah he's a very based guy I'm reading
his uh meditation meditations I just
gotta I ordered a leather-bound copy of
that and I think they had to actually
make it in India because it took me like
two months to get from Amazon
phenomenon says Eugene Carroll is the
same woman who went on Anderson Cooper
and literally said that she thinks rape
I'm not going to read the quote but she
thinks rep is actually what she actually
said was
she said that most people think it is
sexy she didn't say that she did you
know if that distinction matters to you
I don't know that's the quote slightly
off
Mo Harris says they took our jobs
classic yep
Zane Thomas says read Reynolds V Sims
1964 to understand how the blue cities
gained control of the red counties
well interesting what was that again
Reynolds V Sims 1964.
to learn how blue cities gain control of
red counties yeah I'm gonna look that up
Larry Stout's article in the hill has
Biden wanting to use the 14th Amendment
for the budget problem
hmm
well okay some people are saying that
it's unconstitutional crazy Roger page
says Tim Poole and Brian stelter had
meetings I was not allowed to partake in
I don't know what that means I've never
had a meeting with Brian stelter what is
that a reference to is it a joke I'm
missing uh I think so
yep
and YouTube just gave us the jump Rick e
says Trump Hedgehog of 2024
yeah if he's if that is smart uh
Hedgehog I believe so yeah I believe in
Sonic and his middle name is the and
then his last name is Hedgehog and if
Trump is smart that's who he's going to
select as his running mate
um can you
can you relate quite frankly what am I
I'm selecting Sonic's
some people were saying I was going to
pick him about Dave Dames but it's a
race it's a race you have to go some say
you have to go fast
yes but we so he he would have to it
would have to be an arc where he starts
by just relentlessly trashing Sonic
through the primaries little blue Sonic
just ripping them apart and then baby
blue yeah little baby blue Sonic runs
from all his problems and then
eventually it'd be like I like I like
him because he won't get caught I like
him too fast yeah
that's what I'll do
Jessica Cox has been a supporter since
day one Michael is wearing my
boyfriend's band shirt the contortionist
tell Michael Joey B says hi and thanks
for the support yeah they're fans of the
show man oh cool yeah they're great guys
sweet
sounds awesome
krentus the dentist says what do you
think of Bitcoin should we trust in a
currency even though it's not backed by
any
assist or physically Commodities yeah I
know but it says assist oh yeah yeah so
I just read them as they type them by
the way I love the the reference to the
name crunches the dentist good office
reference yeah I don't know everyone
twice try to take the day off and he's
clearly I've never seen it he's like I'm
going to the dentist and then Michael's
like what's his name he's like
oh my gosh you've never seen a single
episode no wow not one you have to
that's funny I'm uh you're an animal
you're uncultured and you want to stay
uncultured and that's fine that's fine
I'll let you live that life zermis
playground says hey Tim for poker with
the boys you should set up a fake
mustache vending machine outside the
door it could be priced at a dollar a
piece but give back 23 cents change
would be hilarious gag coming for
infringed yeah the Bitcoin the problem
with uh oh yeah yeah we're gonna ask
about what do you think about Bitcoin
um I love Bitcoin I got a bunch
there you go it should have bought a
bunch more they say that it's not or
that he was asking it's not backed up by
anything and it's not backed up by what
you normally think of but there was
energy in the form of electricity and
there was a value in that electricity
that was put into it so there is a
certain amount of value in in instilled
into it right yeah the energy required
to make a Bitcoin guarantees the price
of Bitcoin I'm gonna get I'm gonna uh be
a stickler it's not backed by a certain
amount of value it's backed by a certain
amount of utility because the value is
still subjective like like and and and
basically what it is is it it can the
blockchain itself serving as a ledger of
account this infrastructure gives it
gives it a unique quality of money that
no no other money has ever had uh where
you can you can trust it to that extent
because you can't you can't hack Bitcoin
but all all money is is
do people have confidence it can be used
for exchange yeah right and the the
value of Bitcoin isn't actually in the
coins it's in the network yeah correct
in the security and and the ability to
transfer that's easy so someone in chat
said Bitcoin is backed by math and I
misread that as meth for a second and I
was like you know what if there is a a
math standard implemented at some point
that's that's true as for poker with the
boys the problem is poker is illegal in
West Virginia which makes no sense but
Pokemon and Magic the Gathering and
Yu-Gi-Oh are also illegal and I'm not
exaggerating or being cute Yugioh like
Pokemon is it's illegal the the law
explicitly States you can't host any
card game and you cannot play any card
game it doesn't say you can't gamble or
wage your money it literally says you
can't play card games the thing is the
law was likely written before card games
were invented and so the only card games
that existed were card decks with 52
cards you know the same their poker
decks and so the law was written vaguely
then Pokemon Magic the Gathering and
Yu-Gi-Oh emerge and now we have a
constitutional problem
where the state allows children to wager
on games of chance now I know Magic the
Gathering Pokemon have skill in deck
building and strategy and play but the
law says you can't play card games
period Then when a child gives money to
the owner to enter a competition in
which chance plays a role because it's
another important factor the law in West
Virginia does not say to what degree
chance it has it just chance any
so a game where you draw cards and
there's a random chance at getting good
cards or energy or whatever you need
that is a game of chance outside of all
of that I kid you not look up the laws
in West Virginia it says card games are
illegal and when I went and talked to
the government they were like yeah card
games are illegal and I'm like there's
Pokemon and match together all over the
state so how do you how do you control
for one but not the other and I think I
was talking to a state senator and I
said I guess the end result is either
they will ban Pokemon or legalize poker
because you can't it can't both be the
same thing
because it just says card game doesn't
matter how much chances involved I want
to stress that point all right everybody
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com by
clicking that join us button we're gonna
have a members only uncensored show
coming up for you in about 10 minutes
when we go live on the front page of
timcast so definitely sign up you can
follow the show at timcast IRL basically
everywhere you can follow me personally
at timcast Michael do you want to shout
anything out yeah absolutely I mean if
if you agree with what I'm saying as far
as the decentralization and
nullification strategy this is what the
libertarian party is doing you can go to
lp.org join you do not have to change
your registration to become a member of
the party you could just throw some
support and if you want to support the
Visas caucus go to take humanaction.com
and keep the revolution alive
yeah I think I'll actually just give a
shout out to Robert Breedlove who has
the what is money podcast because a lot
of what we were just talking about with
Bitcoin and what is money what our
economics he gets into that pretty
deeply
I actually want to shout out Ben here
because in the in the time before clown
world uh when uh YouTube didn't suck uh
and there was a lot of independent
documentaries Ben was one of the early
Pioneers producing content that was red
pilling people on a deep level with his
documentaries uh uh the Esoteric Agenda
chimatica and ungrip and that he can get
mentioned so those those documentaries
are still out there and they're still
good stuff man and we got one that's uh
just about ready to come out game of
money game of money yeah and it's
perfect timing too because consider all
the banks are collapsing yeah so we're
Ben's actually here so we can figure out
the proper distribution with uh
infringed
we might do a Premiere which means it
might actually take a month we're trying
to get clearance on certain Clips we
want to use so the lawyer's got to go
through it but then the opportunity
there is like okay well for waiting why
don't we get a theater and then do like
an actual premiere of the documentary
which would be cool so we'll see yeah
Sheamus my name is Seamus Coughlin what
I want to shout out is the Novena that
we're praying to St Joseph for the
working class and this tumultuous
economy for The Unborn for our enemies
including the people uh advice uh who
many of whom may be out of work and
Dylan Mulvaney these people who are very
confused that they may see the light and
that our country will return to God so
if you go over to my Twitter that Novena
I just retweeted it we'll we'll be
praying it tonight please join us
I am uh Phil Labonte from the band All
That Remains Phil it remains on Twitter
feel that remains official on Instagram
and the band is All That Remains on
Spotify Apple music YouTube
etc etc
and I am search.com everywhere uh
SoundCloud Instagram Twitter Etc follow
me let's argue we will see all of you
over at timcast.com in a few minutes
thanks for hanging out